les mystiques vous avez entendu la
majorité sénatoriale en temps et bien
voté très largement ce sont les mots de
bruno retailleau tout à l'heure ce pass
vaccinale vous avez entendu hier des
marseille qui lui a indiqué hé bien
qu'il y avait beaucoup de sérénité dans
les débats alors oui voilà une
atmosphère qui tranche avec celle qui
régnait la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale où on a vu les
débats ont été houleux avant et bien
l'adoption de ce pass vaccinale et cette
semaine et bien les sénateurs examinent
ce texte ils en sont encore à l'article
1er celui qui instaure le pass vaccinale
noter qu'ils ont apportés et bien hier
un certain nombre de modifications
significatives sur ce texte le sénat a
notamment supprimé la vérification
d'identité par les hôteliers
restaurateurs voilà un point qui était
prévu par le texte et les sénateurs sont
allés encore plus loin que ce que la
commission avait prévu initialement
notez également que pour les sénateurs
le pass doit pouvoir s'appliquer
seulement à partir de 18 ans et non 16
ans 16 ans et là le seuil qui est prévu
dans la version de l'assemblée nationale
sachez également que les sénateurs
veulent imposer que si certains seuils
épidémiques sont atteints et notamment
si au moins dix mille patients sont
hospitalisés et bien là seulement le
pass vaccinale va pouvoir s'appliquer
sinon il ya une sorte de clause
d'extinction automatique
et puis il y à un dernier changement qui
a été instauré hier et cela a été fait à
nos contrées bien de l'avis du
gouvernement mais si contre l'avis du
rapporteur le sénateur les républicains
philippe bas c'est l instauration de
jauge dans les stades et dans les salles
de spectacles des jauges qui serait
proportionnel au nombre de places alors
vous allez pouvoir suivre dans un
instant tous les débats dans l'hémicycle
à la rédaction de public sénat se
mobilisent pour vous les faire suivre ce
débat qui se poursuivent autour de
l'article 1er ça va là va avoir lieu
avec et bien toute la rédaction de
public sénat présenté par quentin calme
mais on va vous expliquer tous les
enjeux de ce texte notez que ce qu'il y
a un il va y avoir une commission mixte
paritaire qui est également prévue jeudi
mais tout de suite eh bien on va
rejoindre les missiles vous l'avez vu
valérie létard une sénatrice union
centriste est en train de présider la
séance on prend la direction de
l'hémicycle
alain marc et moi même souhaitons ont
voté pour
merci a été donné de votre mise au point
elle sera publiée au journal officiel et
figurera dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin concerné en application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution
ainsi que de la loi organique et de la
loi du 23 juillet 2010 prises pour son
application
la commission des lois a émis lors de sa
réunion de ce jour un avis favorable 23
voix pour 2 voix comptera à la
nomination de monsieur didier les six à
la direction générale de l'office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration
par ailleurs conformément mêmes
dispositions la commission des affaires
économiques a émis lors de sa réunion de
ce jour un avis favorable
12 voix pour 10 voix contre à la
nomination de benoît coeuré à la
présidence l'autorité de la concurrence
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée
renforçant les outils de gestion de la
crise sanitaire et modifiant le code de
santé de la santé publique demande du
gouvernement dans la discussion des
articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 55 rectifié bis au sein de
l'article 1er et nous commençons par une
série de trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 55
rectifié bis madame noël merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il s'agit ici d'un
amendement de repli l'intérêt de la
santé publique étant de s'assurer que
seules les personnes non infectées au
cosy de thé naître dans les lieux
publics pour éviter de propager le virus
on peut considérer que seuls les
détenteurs d'un tests virologiques
répondant à cette exigence al'inverse
des personnes vaccinées dont il est
aujourd'hui fait la preuve qu'elles
peuvent être contaminés et contaminantes
j rajouterai qu il ne faut pas que la
validité du test soit limité à 24 heures
puisque aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'engorgement des centres et des
laboratoires il faut en moyenne 12 à 24
heures justement pour obtenir les
résultats d'un test antigénique ou pcr
donc si on veut que cette mesure soit
encore valable et est encore un sens il
faut véritablement revenir à ce qui est
prêt existant il ya encore quelques
semaines de cela et a ramené la validité
des tests à 72 heures je remercie madame
noël nous passons à la présentation de
la moment 179
et c'est monsieur crinière qu'il
présente merci madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à prendre en compte
les récentes préconisations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
mise par son directeur général qui a
déclaré que des programmes de rappel
sans discernement ont toutes les chances
de prolonger la pandémie
plutôt que d'y mettre fin à cet égard
les annonces trt les annonces du
ministre français de la santé
imposant de facto une dose de rappel
d'abord six mois après la deuxième dose
puis réduisant ce délai à 5 mois et
ensuite à quatre mois est désormais à
trois mois après la deuxième injection
sont caractéristiques d'un programme de
rappel sans discernement quid de la
quatrième dose et de la 5e 2 l'objet de
cet amendement est donc d'assurer de
façon définitive que bénéficier d'un
pass vaccinale des personnes ayant eu
les deux ou trois injections du vaccin
libre à elle ensuite de solliciter les
dose de rappel supplémentaires selon le
rythme qui sera autorisée au niveau
national ou préconisées par les médecins
je reprends les propos du rapporteur
général philippe barrière qui disait que
le parlement veut garder la main sur le
pass vaccinale il faudrait donc adopté
cet amendement car le nombre de doses
est évidemment liée à la délivrance du
pass vacances inhalent grave on dans le
marbre ce nombre de doses qui délivre le
sésame du pass vaccinale et ne laissons
pas l'initiative du gouvernement
d'indiquer le nombre de doses qui demain
pourrait être quatre ou cinq
voilà pourquoi je vous propose de voter
cet amendement merci monsieur klinger et
nous passons la présentation de
l'amendement 3-1 rectifier c'est madame
gosselin qui le présente
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente oui
l'amendement qui est soutenu et proposé
par madame belrhiti cet amendement vise
à inscrire dans la loi que le pass
vaccinale ne pourrait être conditionnée
à plus de trois injections de vaccin
contre la copie 19 ou deux en fonction
des publics pour lesquels il est
autorisé et recommandé alors que des
évaluations de sécurité et d'efficacité
des fabricants n'ont pas été menées à
leur terme concernant la troisième dose
il est nécessaire d'empêcher que ce pass
vaccinale puisse être conditionné à
l'administration de 4,5 voire plusieurs
autres doses supplémentaires et se
passait seulement de quelques mois comme
l'a laissé entendre récemment la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
le vaccin contre la grippe qui est muet
qui est un virus qui mute qui mute
régulièrement est limitée à une
injection par an
d'autres vaccins au cours de la vie sont
espacés de 10 ans
l'administration d'autant dose an d
intervalle aussi court à une grande
majorité de la population quand il
constituerait une première et ne serait
pas raisonnable de soumettre les
français à un tel rythme vaccinale qui
plus est quand leur emploi leur vie
sociale familiale professionnelle en
dépend merci merci chaque collègue et
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole pour donner l'avis de la
commission sur ces trois amendements
bien volontiers madame la présidente sur
le 55 rectifié bis il est contraire à la
position de la commission et par
conséquent de l'avis est défavorable
sur le 179 et le 3 rectifier il ouvre un
débat intéressant
parce que
la notion de vaccination complète
et évolutive
elle est à coup sûr évolutif elle a
d'ailleurs évolué nous ne savions pas au
mois de février de l'année dernière
qu'il faudrait une seconde injection et
quand la seconde injection a été fait
nous ne savions pas
qu'il fallait
au bout d'un certain nombre de mois pour
pallier la baisse d'immunité de
l'organisme fait rappelle qu'au moment
où je vous parle nous ne savons pas si
dans six mois
l'épidémie sera toujours là d'une part
et si d'autre part il sera alors
nécessaire compte tenu de ce qu'on aura
observé
de l'efficacité
du vaccin
sur l'organisme
il faudra ou non une quatrième élection
personne ne se plaint quand il se fait
vacciner contre la grippe de devoir
refaire
une vaccination chaque année mais
déterminés à l'avance
le nombre
d'injections nécessaires pour assurer le
maintien d'une protection suffisante
personne ne vous dira que c'est possible
alors je me sens vraiment
incapable et la commission avec moi de
donner un avis favorable sur ces deux
amendements que vous avez proposé étant
entendu que ça n'est pas une décision
politique
de savoir si on a besoin d'un rappel et
puis ensuite au bout de quelques mois
d'un second rappel c'est véritablement
une décision qui nous est imposée par
les données de la science je ne connais
pas de gouvernement sur la planète qui
s'amusent à
exiger des injections s'il n'y a pas un
consensus
médical et scientifique pour
considérer que la protection rend
nécessaire ces injections et que la
situation de l'épidémie le rend aussi
nécessaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons donné un avis négatif
à ces amendements 79 et 3 rectifié dont
je comprends moins bien que l'intention
de leur auteur est aussi de ne pas
laisser les mains libres au gouvernement
pour changer les conditions d'accès au
pass vaccinale mais enfin je vous salue
de pouvoir vous projetez à un horizon de
six mois ou un an j'espère fort compte
tenu du comportement du variant au micro
que la question ne se posera même pas
merci monsieur le rapporteur mesures
merci monsieur le ministre avis
défavorable du gouvernement sur ces
trois amendements jeu mais avant de
mettre aux voix je vais donner la parole
pour explication de vote à monsieur rsa
si madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
j'avoue je voudrais intervenir sur le
premier de ces amendements celui
présenté par madame noël j'avoue que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de difficulté à
comprendre pourquoi monsieur le
rapporteur en monsieur le ministre vous
donner un avis défavorable à cet
amendement qui vise simplement à
reconnaître la validité d'un test
négatif pour entrer dans les lieux
soumis à passe
si j'ai bien compris l'intérêt de ce
débat il s'agit effectivement à travers
ses passes d'éviter d'entrer dans des
locaux où les personnes peuvent
contaminer voir se contaminer elle même
bien lorsque à tout le moins on présente
impasse un pardon un test négatif c'est
que encore une fois beaucoup plus qu'eux
le vaccin dont on a dit tout à l'heure
qu'il permettait aussi la contagion il
permettait d'ailleurs aussi de
contracter la maladie beaucoup plus
qu'un vaccin c'est une assurance que la
personne qui arrive et qui pénètre dans
ses locaux n'est pas malade donc
pourquoi je répète
conformément à la stratégie mise en
oeuvre par ce gouvernement refuser de
prendre en compte ceux ce test négatif à
partir du moment où ici la haute
assemblée a déjà accepté le pass
vaccinale en quoi ce serait gênant de
rajouter un test négatif
donc vraiment excusez moi d'insister sur
cela mais il y à là pour moi un non sens
monsieur le premier ministre vient
encore de dire tout à l'heure pendant la
séance de questions que il s'agissait de
tester tester tester toujours plus il a
cité plusieurs millions de tests à ce
jour mais à quoi ils servent ces tests
qui effectivement ne les prend pas en
compte pour entrer dans les lieux soumis
à passe je vous remercie pour ma part
naturellement je voterai cet amendement
merci monsieur laissa la parole et à
monsieur offert pour explication de vote
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
le rapporteur a dit
que le but de ces trois
amendements était de ne pas laisser les
mains libres au gouvernement je
non je pense pas je pense que dans la
vie on ne se pose pas en s'opposant
et je n'ose pas dire que cette réponse
est absurde parce que un test négatif
est le summum de la protection quelqu'un
qui est testé négatif ne peut pas
programmer page et alors que à vacciner
qui n'est de toute façon va tester et on
le sait et on le voit tous les jours
peut propager la propager la maladie
donc moi je vous ferai des deux mains le
rapport de madame noël et je fais comme
andré reichardt je trouve je ne
comprends pas la réaction de la
commission
merci monsieur ou perdre ses paroles
mêmes chefs un
merci madame la présidente de smith mes
chers collègues donc si j'ai bien
compris nos collègues qui viennent de
s'exprimer donc
effectivement il serait nécessaire de
faire un test losc on va dans les lieux
publics alors les mecs j'oserais rappelé
le rôle de la vaccination la la
vaccination c'est pour protéger les
personnes
c'est à dire que pour que nos
concitoyens n'ont beau lisent pas la
réanimation
où certains certains soirs pour où se
trouvent les personnes en situation
grave c'est fait pour ça et donc pour
que les personnes bien et un coville qui
ne soit pas trop grave
et deuxièmement effectivement pour aller
c'est l'amendement que j'avais fait hier
pour aller dans certaines lui dans
certains lieux publics ciblés
comme les ehpad ou comme certains
établissements médico sociaux
malgré la vaccination la vaccination
bien sûr il faut la faire c'est à prüm
indispensable mais malgré la vaccination
on peut avoir des personnes vaccinées
qui sont contagieuses mais effectivement
qui sont asymptomatiques
et effectivement il serait nécessaire en
plus de la vaccination d'avoir dans
certains je répète établissements ciblés
un test pour qu' ils ne viennent pas
contaminer des personnes bien sûr dans
ces établissements elles sont vacciner
les personnels ont les trois doses mais
comme elles ont un état général qui est
mauvais des fois des insuffisances
respiratoires et la moindre la moindre
infection peut les aggraver donc
effectivement si c'est cet esprit je
voterai la maman à condition que ce soit
bien dans cet esprit merci monsieur marc
tout en discussion commune de façon
assez étrange d'ailleurs moi je
m'exprime et surtout pas sur celui de
madame noël mais sur les sur les deux
autres et je trouve que la position de
notre rapporteur est une une décision
empreinte de sagesse on ne peut pas un
effet préjuger de ce que va devenir la
pandémie je veux tourner tous les uns et
les autres que dans six mois nous
n'ayons plus à évoquer ce sujet mais
pour l'instant fixée dans le marbre les
critères du pass vaccinale nous sommes
de tout à fait prématuré et ne me semble
pas être de bon aloi donc bien
évidemment je ne vois tu aurais pas ces
deux amendements
merci la parole et amada mercier
le sionisme est cher collègue
effectivement ça peut sembler au premier
abord un peu bizarre de penser que
quelqu'un qui a un test négatif et qui
n'est pas vacciné n'est donc pas
dangereux pour les autres c'est vrai
c'est vrai il un test négatif mais comme
il n'est pas vaccinée c'est dangereux si
cette personne attrape le virus parce
qu'elle aura plus de risques de faire
une maladie grave dont tu de se
retrouver en réanimation et donc de
contribuer à lobo lisation de nos
services de réanimation c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien comprendre qu'il vaut
mieux une personne vaccinée même si
elles portent quelquefois le virus
qu'une personnes non vaccinées avec un
test négatif
et madame mercier la parole est à madame
noël
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je pense qu'il s'agit là
d'une question quand même assez
essentielle du texte et votre simple
réponse de dire avis défavorable pour
moi me convient pas je pense que vous
devez vous expliquer sur le sens de
votre avis défavorable je pense que la
représentation nationale le mérite merci
si madame noël la parole est à monsieur
je vieillis
merci madame la présidente le premier
amendement utilise à revenir au pad
sanitaire au lieu du pass vaccinale pas
faut parler clairement bon donc voilà on
porte on peut continuer la discussion
sur chaque amendement sur cette question
et on n'en sortira pas nous on a
expliqué pourquoi on pensait que c'était
mal fondées que l'obligation fonderait
le principe est donc après effectivement
la discussion très claire elle est un
peu confuse donc contente de 100 à 1
euro
l'amendement numéro 3
le problème c'est que c'est un
amendement qui vise encore une fois
discréditer le vaccin derrière des
arguments néo scientifique le rapporteur
l'a dit la connaissant ça se construit
ce vaccin a des très bonnes qualités il
protège très bien des formes graves il
est moins bon sur d'autres choses ça
durait d'immunisation n'est pas très
bonne on espère que les vaccins sûrs en
serons meilleurs effectivement ce sera
pas 4 mois 6 mois à 8 mois j'en sais
rien ce sera plus long et puis par
ailleurs iru pas de façon satisfaisante
la chaîne de transmission il ne fait que
réduire donc effectivement il n'est pas
excellent et vous à partir de là vous
apporter des amendements il faut lire
vos exposé des motifs qui visent à le
discréditer
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
ministre répond régulièrement
parlementaire et d'une façon que nous
soutenons sur cette question mais moi je
voudrais que le ministre réponde aussi
publiquement à ceux qui tiennent ces
propos et depuis quelques jours le
directeur de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires méditerranée le
professeur out tient des propos qui
discrédite le vaccin cet institut est
financé largement sur fonds publics ça
devrait être le vaisseau amiral des
maladies infectieuses en france c'est la
boussole qui indique le sud et le
maintien de didier rahout à la direction
de 7,6 à chu est un scandale national il
décrivit billy's notre politique
sanitaire il désorienté français il
alimente le discours ans steve at il
faut prendre vos responsabilités
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre parlant encore une fois le même
lapsus
décidément il faut prendre vos
responsabilités lui répondre
publiquement
la parole et à monsieur alain milon
merci alain présente je vais pas revenir
sur crucell dire bernard jomier sur l'ia
chu de marseille c'est à dire que je
suis entièrement d'accord avec lui et
que j'espère que monsieur raout prendra
sa retraite le plus vite possible je
voudrais revenir sur les d les
amendements d'abord celui de madame noël
et je rejoins marie mercier sur ce sujet
si on adopte si vous adoptez un
amendement de marie noëlle le vaccin ne
sert plus à rien le pass vaccinale ne
sert plus à rien d'ailleurs c'est déjà
ça c'est ça qui est important où on fait
le vaccin et on protège et si on fait le
peu ce qu'on demande annuelle on
supprime le vaccin ne protège plus donc
il est nécessaire de continuer de
protéger la population je vais revenir
aussi sur d'amples amendement de madame
belrhiti dire que on vaccine une fois
par an contre la grippe qu'on vaccine
contre la rougeole deux ou trois fois
dans la vie et faire céder comparaison
de ce type là n'ont pas lieu d'être nous
sommes en phase de virus ou de bactéries
qui sont complètement différents et qui
ont des actions différentes levage
reprendre le virus de la grippe parce
que ça me semble être le plus important
puisque on se vaccine une fois par an le
virus de la grippe a en effet minutes
mais umüt de façon saisonnière et quand
il est dans l'hémisphère sud il n'est
pas dans l'hémisphère nord et quand il
est dans l'essai en or il n'est plus
dans l'hémisphère sud qui nous permet
d'avoir donc des vaccins saisonniers
annuel efficace ce virus le sascoc deux
que nous voyons actuellement une mue
tenons pas de façon saisonnière mais de
façon régulière et quasiment tous les
deux ou trois mois et nous ne sommes pas
sûr d'ailleurs là je rejoins
complètement de ministre et monsieur le
rapporteur nous ne sommes pas sûrs que
omicron soit le dernier vario il est
probable d'ailleurs du fait de cette
capacité importante du virus un avariée
a muté il est probable qu'on puisse
retrouver un jour je le dis à chaque
fois mais je redis aujourd'hui est
probable qu'on puisse se retrouver un
jour face à un mutant qui soit à
échappement vaccinale donc vaccinons 26
noms et n'essayons pas de dire qu'il ne
faut pas vacciner pour protéger les
populations celle inverse il faut
vacciner pour protéger l'ensemble de des
populations nos populations d'abord les
populations des pays qui elles n'ont pas
les moyens qui eux pardon n'ont pas les
moyens de se payer ces vaccins
merci monsieur milan avant de laisser la
parole à monsieur vial pour explication
de vote
vous dire que je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur le moment
55 rectifié biz ça permettra à nos
collègues de préparer leur vote
monsieur vial vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente sur la porte
un de ses ministres je voudrais
intervenir essentiellement sur le sur
les abondantes de mes collègues klinger
et et belrhiti
vous avez dit monsieur le rapporteur que
ces amendements avaient le mérite de
poser un débat et justement je
souhaiterais qu'on puisse profiter de la
présence du ministre pour avoir ce débat
ici le débat il est sur la définition
d'un schéma vaccinal complet il est
aussi un enjeu de santé publique
puisqu'il suffit pas de fixer une règle
ou d'imposer une contrainte il faut
encore convaincre nos compatriotes de
d'accepter ces règles et donc pour cela
de les comprendre et je pense que c'est
une des difficultés contre le
gouvernement depuis un certain temps
c'est dans cette pédagogie je ne crois
pas la pédagogie de l'insulté choque
personne de ces c'est l'efficacité de
celle-ci par contre je crois à la
pédagogie par l'explication est
aujourd'hui on se pose un certain nombre
de questions les françaises pose un
certain nombre de questions qu'est-ce
qu'un schéma vaccinal complet c'est vous
avez communiqué au début en disant qu'il
fallait au bout de six mois pour refaire
une dose et on avait entre 6 et une once
étaient cinq mois entre 5 et 7 mois puis
ensuite quatre mois puis ensuite trois
mois mais on n'a jamais entendu parler
de la deuxième partie de la fourchette
c'est à dire à partir de quand le schéma
vaccinal dès qu'on n'est plus considéré
comme complet est-ce que c'est toujours
à partir de sept mois est ce que vous
êtes est ce que ces deux mois après la
période à laquelle on a accès au vaccin
on a besoin que gouvernement nous dise à
partir de quand le schéma vaccinal n'est
plus complet donc le pass vaccinale
n'est plus complet c'est une information
importante deuxièmement ça a été dit un
certain nombre de variants et dans
l'acceptabilité on a besoin de savoir un
peu où on va j'ai fait le calcul moi je
serai à ma cinquième dose pas juillet à
la fin du texte de loi les personnes un
peu plus âgés que moi en seront à leur
sixième doses si on respecte ce schéma
de vaccination tous les trois mois on a
besoin de savoir un peu où on va les
vaccins n'ont pas tous la même
acceptabilité aujourd'hui y aller les
gens ont accepté comme comprennent le
vaccin notamment faiza ruhr derna on
sait que d'autres sont en préparation
l'acceptabilité sera peut-être pas
immédiatement la même on a besoin de
savoir monsieur le ministre comment ça
va se passer et combien de temps le pass
vaccinale sera valable ar mais la
période à laquelle est ouverte avec ciné
merci nos collègues la parole est à mme
selon à porter
madame la présidente j'ai eu un remords
parce que on entend dans les
interventions de plusieurs de nos
collègues je me suis aperçu que
s'agissant de l'amendement numéro 55
rectifié bis de madame noël plusieurs de
nos collègues je m'étais contenté de
dire que la vie était d'un forum parce
que cet amendement était contraire à la
position de la commission
ça ne m'a pas permis
voulant être concis
d'expliquer plus amplement les raisons
mais mes chers collègues tout simplement
ce débat n'a pas seulement été tranchée
par la commission il a été tranché par
vous-même hier
c'est la question de savoir si on
accepte ou non le pass vaccinale nos
collègues avec cet amendement supprime
le pass vaccinale que vous avez adopté
hier c'est clair et net même si la
présentation peut parfois être
malicieuse mais c'est bien ça l'objet
exact et précis de cet amendement et
c'est parce que vous avez voté le pass
vaccinale hier que je vous ai recommandé
de ne pas le défaire aujourd'hui je suis
bien certain que ce serait cohérent avec
vos propres voter je tenais à reprendre
la parole pour bien expliciter le
contenu de cet amendement pour pas que
ans l'interprète sur des bases erronées
il s'agit d'un amendement de suppression
du pass vaccinale comme vous en avez
rejeté déjà plusieurs dans la journée
d'hier il rouvre un débat qui était clos
par votre vote
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à madame kuperman pour
explication merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je crois tout d'abord vous savez pour
des raisons de fond et sur les questions
compris de liberté individuelle notre
groupe n'a pas voté le pass sanitaires
et ne votera pas la validation de cet
article premier qui instaure
effectivement le pass vaccin sur ces
trois amendements nous ne le voterons
pas non plus parce que et je veux le
redire ici la question n'est pas de
discréditer le déploiement vaccinale
dans notre dans notre pays et nous ne
pouvons pas effectivement et je crois
que cela a été dit par un certain nombre
de nos collègues précédemment
mettre en balance
l'enjeu la nécessité y compris une
faisons partie de ceux qui n'ont de
cesse de dire qu'il faut encore faire
plus davantage pour aller voir pour
aller convaincre sans stigmatiser ceux
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas vaccinés
n'ont pas accès aux vaccins et donc on
ne peut pas simplement mettre je disais
en parallèle le déploiement vaccinale et
la réalisation de tests je me
permettrait également de rajouter parce
que je crois que c'est d'actualité et
nous le vivons tout les tous dans tous
nos départements
faut-il il convient aujourd'hui
multiplier le nombre de personnes ayant
recours à des tests quand on voit les
difficultés et l'engorgement
dans l'augmentation de files d'attentes
pour pouvoir se faire tester pour toutes
les personnes qui en ont besoin et donc
pour toutes ces raisons part sur la
question des tests parce qu'en terme de
doses et de vaccins au moins je suis
très tranquille chpa épidémiologie
surtout pas la prétention de le devenir
mais une chose est certaine c'est avec
beaucoup d'humilité l'avenir dira
combien de doses il nous faudra pour
pouvoir en sortir donc nous ne voterons
pas ses trois amis
merci madame petermann la parole est à
monsieur benarroch
je rentrais l'amendement de madame noël
et je ne suis pas surpris en fait que le
ministre vous ai pas répondu madame noël
et monsieur richard en fait on peut
deviner sa réponse au fait
indéniablement tout le monde le
reconnaît y compris les personnes parmi
nous qui sont pour le pass vaccinale il
est vrai que faire un test négatif
permet d'être assuré beaucoup mieux que
par passe vaccinale est un vaccin que
vous n'avez aucune chance de contaminer
les personnes que vous allez voir dans
la journée je pense que personne ne peut
dire l'averse ici par contre la réponse
je la comprends très bien c'est pas
parce qu'on a un pass vaccinale si c'est
pas parce que nous avons un test négatif
que pour autant que pour autant
nous nous devons supprimer le vaccin le
vaccin a toute sa raison d'être dans le
fait qu'ils évitent les formes graves et
donc quand on a compris ces deux termes
de l'alternative
et quand on connaît la position du
gouvernement qui commence maintenant l
affirmer d'une manière plus claire voir
les déclarations de monsieur le ministre
ici présents aujourd'hui on a bien
compris que le fait de pas contaminée
n'était pas souci aujourd'hui du
gouvernement la diffusion du virus n'est
plus le souci de cette loi le problème
n'est plus que le virus ne soit pas de
se diffuser ça a été dit x x y compris
par lui disent nous ne pouvons pas
lutter contre la propagation du virus au
micro je pense que monsieur le ministre
a en outre confirmé c'est encore ce
qu'il a dit aujourd'hui rajoutant même
que les mesures traditionnelles n'avait
plus aucune raison d'être et que donc
les copines mayotte ne servait plus à
rien puisque le virus de toute façon
dans les endroits où c'est où les gens
sont quand tu sors confiner le virus de
toute façon lorsqu'ils se rendent et
confiné se propagera auprès de tout le
monde te clé les objectifs ne sont pas
le mail et même quand vous défendez 7 à
cet amendement qui est fort que je
voterai c'est uniquement pour permettre
d'être certain qu'un certain nombre de
personnes ne sont pas contaminantes et
quand le ministre ou le rapporteur
disent ce n'est pas le cas c'est parce
que 6 il faut se vacciner pour éviter
les formes graves et l'engorgement des
hôpitaux six ans de chances qu'un seul
candidat mais on peut en parler pendant
des jours et des jours comme hier nous
n'arriverons pas merci merci chers
confrères mais il faut que vous avez
dépassé votre temps de parole alors
avant de laisser la parole à monsieur le
ministre y at il d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
monsieur morin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
par cohérence je voterai évidemment ces
amendements puisque j'ai pas voté parce
d'accident le vrai problème c'est que
cette stratégie du tout vaccins pour
tout le monde
mais si c'est ça le vrai problème c'est
d'aller vers la vérité et c'est de
trouver en toute humilité essaie de
comprendre les choses ça fait deux ans
ça fait deux ans et vous avez choisi et
l'analogie avec la grippe est une très
bonne remarque quand on a la grippe on
ne demande pas on n'oblige pas à tout le
monde à être vaccinés et la question de
tout à l'heure de savoir combien de
vaccins faut-il être
vaccinés combien ils font souvent eh
bien c'est comme ça interroge quand même
et il est la question du consentement
est aussi une question qui érode la
question du tout vaccin c'est se pose
aussi la question qu'est ce qui à côté
des soins des médicaments la question
c'est aussi depuis deux ans et forcément
la mise à niveau de notre système de
soins c'est aussi la question de la
crédibilité de la parole publique et
d'un peu d'humilité parce qu'aujourd'hui
personne ne peut le dire quelle sera la
vérité 3 4 5 6 jusqu'où on va accepter
cela et comme tout être chose vivante le
virus est la dernière où est ce que j'ai
trouvé à travers l'histoire c'est la rue
dont hong kong bon quand est-ce que ça a
paru long qu'on en juillet 68 en france
ça a disparu en des 170 pourquoi cette
politique de la peur
pourquoi cette politique de la
culpabilisation des français pourquoi
ces commentaires très douloureux est
regrettable du chef de l'état qui
devrait être là pour rassurer pour
expliquer pour dégager un chemin une
vision positive pour l'avenir et bien
non vous avez choisi de continuer parce
que cette religion du vaccin et c'est
quand même pas pareil au micron
aujourd'hui que ce qui est avait il ya
deux ans on sait très bien que c'est
quand même beaucoup moins l'étape tout
le monde le sait on le voit bien sur
nous dans nos hôpitaux bon alors
pourquoi s'entêter pas ça c'est sûr que
la cohérence dans l'erreur on veut dire
qu'elle prospère un donc moi évidemment
je voterai et j'appelle un retour à
l'esprit critique à la liberté au bon
sens merci merci monsieur meuron la
parole est à mme anna mula roanne
merci madame la présidente je voulais
revenir sur la notion d'acceptabilité
et en revenant sur l'aliment demandé ma
collègue madame noël en effet vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure que là le test
négatif sur une personnes non vaccinées
va en fait c'est pour la protéger d'une
forme grave parce que si elles
développent levac la maladie elle va
être hospitalisé est engorgé les
services hospitaliers et cette notion
d'acceptabilité
en fait la personne qui est non vaccinés
aujourd'hui elle a peut-être peur elle a
peut être peur parce que nous ne parlons
pas là nous n'évoquons pas tout ce qui
existe comme effets
indésirables et toutes les tous les
dégâts et tous les accidents après la
vaccination
il faut les évoquer aussi est
aujourd'hui une personne qui n'est pas
vaccinée comment lui rendre acceptable
que des personnes qui étaient en pleine
santé et bien ont un problème après la
vaccination et c'est quand même à s'être
connus vous avez auditionné la
directrice de la rsm qui a bien confirmé
qu' on a plus de 110000 effets
secondaires indésirables plus ou moins
graves
si c'est les chutes je vais terminer si
vous voulez bien alors que sur d'autres
maladies cumulé on est à beaucoup moins
et on ne peut pas ne pas prendre en
compte nous avons tous des citoyens qui
nous écrivent est qui et qui évoquent et
qui évoque les effets secondaires
indésirables et ses problèmes de santé
donc voilà l'accessibilité pour les non
vaccinés c'est aussi ça être rassurés et
on entend beaucoup de problématiques
suite à l'injection du vaccin merci
merci madame alors je vais maintenant
donner la parole à monsieur le ministre
pour conclure cette longue discussion
la présidence d'honneur de messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord c'est vrai que le
premier amendement celui sur lequel il
ya un scrutin public quand on dit c'est
le pass vaccinale mais si on n'est pas
vaccinée en présente un test négatif
ça s'appelle un pass sanitaires et vous
vous êtes exprimé à de nombreuses
reprises cgt présent hier lors du début
au moins du début de l'examen de cet
article premier c'est pour ça que je
rejoins totalement le rapporteur bas je
me suis permis de ne pas intervenir sur
ce sujet j'entends j'entends beaucoup de
choses il ya des choses qu'on peut
comprendre dans des certaines
appréhensions et des discours qui me
qui pique un peu plus
et pardonnez moi de le dire on a déjà eu
des débats scientifiques dans cet
hémicycle et d'ailleurs c'est tout à
fait légitime d'en débattre mais j'ai
déjà eu des débats où on disait mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'autorisez pas
ça puisque c'est une évidence et tout le
monde vous dit pourquoi vous en ferez
dans vos erreurs la première fois
c'était la chloroquine dams et messieurs
les sénateurs est ce que l'un d'entre
vous aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a au
moins mais cela va beaucoup aujourd'hui
qui regrette que je n'ai pas autorisée
par arrêté la prescription at vitam
aeternam à qu'il voudrait de
l'hydraulique l'euro qui dans notre pays
est-ce qu'il y en a aujourd'hui qui est
capable de dire je peut-être qu'à
l'époque quand j'ai mis la pression sur
le ministre sur les équipes de la dgs
peut-être qu'on sait on est allé un
petit peu vite bon donc pour vous dire
que c'est pour ça que chacun chacun
pardonnez-moi doit mettre de l'eau à son
moulin et essayer dans le calme de
raisonner et de remettre la science au
milieu du village
le discours qui consiste à dire les
vaccins j'en ai marre j'ai été vacciné
deux fois j'étais que ces attaques ne
trois fois vous commencez à dire
peut-être que je ferai vacciner quatre
fois j'entends la lassitude vaccinale la
fatigue vaccinale le ras-le-bol
vaccinale quel que soit le terme que
vous devrez y est employé moi je
considère que le vaccin est une chance
vous savez tout le monde a le droit de
considérer que c'est pas une chance moi
je considère que c'est une chance
je suis pas le seul l'organisation
mondiale de la santé la totalité des
pays qui vaccinent dans le monde
considère que le vaccin est une
opportunité extraordinaire qui nous a
permis d'éviter de décimer des pans
entiers de la population considérant la
contagiosité des variants qui ont
succédé aux premiers comics 19 et l
agressivité notamment d'une variante
delta et je peux considérer sans grand
risque de me tromper puisque c'est pas
le mieux la santé français qui vous le
dit c'est l'ensemble des ministres au
niveau planétaire qui le disent et
surtout des scientifiques que si nous
n'avions pas eu ce vaccin que certains
regardent avec un peu de dépit ou un peu
de lassitude si on n'avait pas eu ce
vaccin on aurait eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus de morts je pense qu on
peut déjà s'entendre sur ce constat une
fois qu'on se dise à combien de fois on
vaccine on vaccine quand on a besoin
d'avoir un système immunitaire efficace
capable de produire des défenses contre
le virus
pourquoi au début six mois et ensuite
trois mois avant le rappel
d'abord nous regardons les études on
prend des personnes qui ont été
vaccinées depuis un mois depuis deux
mois depuis trois mois qu'ils ont eu
deux doses et on regarde le niveau
d'efficacité du système immunitaire qui
tombent malades qui fait des formes
graves etc on fait des statistiques et
on regarde au bout de trois mois ça
commence à baisser un peu au bout de
quatre mois sa baisse quand même pas mal
au bout de cinq mois à l'immunité elle
est quand même affaiblie après la
deuxième dose au bout de six mois on
peut considérer que l'immunité n'est
plus assez efficace donc on commence par
dire le vuleta circulation du virus on
sait déjà qu'au bout de six mois il faut
refaire une un rappel mais le virus
circule davantage les données safin à
l'échelle planétaire on se rend compte
qu'en fait au bout de trois mois
l'immunité pourrait connaître meilleur
et que vu ce qui est en train de
circuler sur la planète le delta l'eau
mikron il vaut mieux ne pas attendre
plus avant et renforcer l'immunité des
gens en proposant un rappel à trois mois
ce que font encore une fois la quasi
totalité des pays occidentaux 1 on n'est
pas en train de parler d'une situation
française
donc si on constate qu'à l'issue la
troisième dose au bout de x men ou 2x
mois à l'immunité devait commencer à
baisser si nous constations qu'il y
avait un nouveau variant qui
apparaissait est potentiellement
dangereux pour emmener les gens à
l'hôpital et créent des et faire des
morts entraîné des morts alors nous
dirions très naturellement vos systèmes
immunitaires qui ont été protégés
pendant des mois par la vaccination
aujourd'hui ne le sont plus assez et
donc on va vous proposer un rappel est
ce que c'est aux personnes fragiles est
ce que c'est à tout la population etc
mais pardonnez moi le discours qui
consiste à dire à moi j'ai été baptisé
déjà deux trois fois j'en ai marre je
comprends ça mais vous avez mois vous
allez mettez vous dans les situations de
quelqu'un qui fait des infections
urinaires à répétition
il a une infection urinaire et prennent
antibiotiques qui guérit trois ans plus
tard il fait une cystite il prend les
antibiotiques guéri trois fois quatre
fois cinq fois il n'a pas de bol mais ça
arrive avec des déformations des
fragilités il fait des cystites à
répétition vous croyez qu'au bout de la
cinquième fois il va dire moi j'arrête
les antibiotiques tant pis non on a
trouvé on a la chance d'avoir quelque
chose qui soigne qui préserve qui
protège qui sauvent des vies qui empêche
aller à l'hôpital on utilise et on le
considère aussi comme ça moi je
pardonnez moi je chaque chaque opinion
peut s'exprimer je sais que les temps
des débats parlementaires vous sont
comptés mais pour rebondir soucis a dit
le sénateur jonnier je le rejoins
monsieur jonnier sur sur ce point là je
j'aimerais qu'il y ait un peu plus de
voix qu'ils se fassent entendre pour
promouvoir le vaccin vous avez été un
certain nombre à le faire mais toutes
les petites attaques toutes les petites
piques qui sont portés les effets
indésirables
intel a dit qu' on pense que est ce
qu'on est sûr que tout cela mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs participe je le
pense en sincérité je le pense en
sincérité a créé de la confusion chez
nos concitoyens qui vous regardent qui
vous écoute et cela ne nous aide pas à
atteindre la couverture vaccinale que
nous espérons avoir et que vous
m'invitez en règle générale à attendre
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais dit monsieur le sénateur
s'était du groupe écologiste j'ai jamais
dit que nous n'essayons pas nous
n'essayons pu lutter pour la diffusion
du virus j'ai dit que les armes étaient
différentes physique avec le variant
delta avec une contagiosité 1er qui
était aux environs de 3 donc une
capacité à se multiplier par deux tous
les dix à douze jours des mesures de
jauge de freinage classique celle que
nous avions utilisé depuis près de deux
ans dans notre pays avait une efficacité
avérée et permettait de freiner physique
en revanche l'euro mikron parce qu'ils
doublent tous les deux jours
spontanément ne pouvons pas de toute
façon freiner sa course au fond nous on
l'a retardé un peu ne pourront pas la
freiner et dans la mesure où un nombre
importants de contamination n'entraîne
pas d un afflux massif et brutale de
patients à l'hôpital c'est quelque chose
qui me semble au regard de deux des
externalités négatives d'un confinement
généralisée pour notre pays justifiait
qu'on ne confine pas je veux vraiment
qu'on précise des choses nous luttons
contre la circulation du virus est
contre la diffusion du virus d'où le
télétravail par exemple sinon y'aurait
pas de télétravail dans ce pays on
dirait aux gens allaient travailler
normalement et ô doux les protocoles
scolaire parce qu'on veut pas que les
enfants se contaminent plus avant en
tout cas on peut limiter au maximum bref
voilà j'ai fait une réponse longue en
espérant avoir été en espérant avoir été
complet s'il dernière question qui était
posée que j'entends aussi souvent et
pourquoi vous vacciner tout le monde et
pas simplement les personnes fragile
c'est vrai c'est les personnes fragiles
qui vont en réanimation et messieurs les
sénateurs à un virus ont l'attrapa sur
la poignée d'une porte on la trappe
parce que quelqu'un nous le transmet et
je veux dire notre pays a suffisamment
payé pour savoir que lorsque les jeunes
se contaminent et qu'on dit bah ça va il
n'y a pas de cas hospitalier on sait
très bien qu après la vague des jeunes
suit la vague des moins jeunes c'est
arrivé dans les bouches du rhône dans
les alpes-maritimes souvenez vous
c'était le début de la deuxième vague
vous aviez des scientifiques il l est
sont les jeunes se contaminer à la
rigueur puisqu'il faut rien c'est pas
grave ça circulera sauf que derrière ils
ont contaminé les parents les
grands-parents la boulangère excédera si
tard on doit pouvoir se protéger
collectivement pour ça aussi qu'on parle
d'action citoyenne et par ailleurs je
voudrais invite à appeler les médecins
des hôpitaux du territoire et à leur
demander l'âge moyen des patients et
surtout s'ils ont des patients qui sont
jeunes vous serez surpris pour un
certain nombre d'entre vous je pense de
constater que dans nos hôpitaux pas
forcément réa mais dans nos hôpitaux ces
trentenaires et quadragénaires et
quinquagénaires bon pied bon oeil bon
pied bon oeil font des formes qui
justifie des recours à l'oxygène je ne
recommande à personne de se retrouver un
jour dans un lit d'hôpital avec des
besoin d'oxygène pour respirer
correctement nous avons la possibilité
de les protéger avec un bac 5 est sûre
et efficace encore une fois c'est une
chance pour l'humanité je pèse mes mots
et nous avons l'occasion là avec ces
débats d'envoyer le bon message à la
population je vous remercie merci
monsieur ministre m alors j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par la
commission sur l'amendement 55 rectifié
bis je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable et que l'avis
du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà vous êtes en direct sur public
sénat et vous le vivez sur notre antenne
et il y en ce moment un scrutin public
c'est à dire que au lieu de voter à main
levée les sénateurs vont pouvoir voter
avec leur carte de vote on va voir dans
un instant une photographie complète du
vote sur un amendement qui a été déposée
par des sénateurs est l air et qui visez
bien en quelque sorte à revenir du pass
vaccinale au pass sanitaire puisque cet
amendement est bien permettrait d'avoir
un test et non pas simplement la
vaccination dans son passé on l'entend
depuis à peu près une demi heure il y as
en séance eh bien un débat autour de la
vaccination autour du pass vaccinale
avec la prise de parole de plusieurs
sénateurs qui sont très sceptiques sur
l'utilité du pass est vaccinale est
aussi sur l'utilité de la vaccination
tout court ça fait un peu polémique 1 en
séance puisque on a entendu un peu de
chahut notamment lorsqu une sénatrice lr
a pu évoquer les effets secondaires
indésirables donc on va voir dans un
instant que les antilles parce vaccinale
vont pouvoir se compter dans l'hémicycle
et donc ça donne ce débat qui a lieu en
ce moment dans l'hémicycle allons vivre
elle se battait et on se retrouve juste
après
mais
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 72
sur l'amendement 55 rectifié 10 compte
tenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordés par les sénateurs au
groupe politique est notifiée à la
présidence nombre de votants 335 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
332 pour l'adoption 12 contre 320 le
sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons au vote sur le 179 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
[Musique]
et qui est contre
ça ce n'est pas adopté le 3 rectifié a
reçu deux avis défavorables même vote
même vote qui n'est pas adopté trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 90 rectifié terre
madame drexler le présente merci madame
la présidente alors cet amendement est
de bon sens puisqu'il s'agit de prendre
en compte l' immunité évalué par tests
sérologiques pour octroyer par
dérogation le pass vaccinale alors je
vais évoquer rapidement mon cas
personnel qui n'est pas isolé pour vous
en expliquer le sens j'ai le coc vide en
mars 2020 vacciner une seule fois en
juin 2021 depuis je fais des sérologies
tous les deux mois et mon taux
d'anticorps s curieusement mais
heureusement très élevé il est même
indiqué dans les résultats que je reçois
je cite que mon taux dit gg témoigne du
caractère récent de l'infection par le
strass cov 2 ou du résultat d'une
vaccination récente pourtant dans
quelques jours sept mois après ma
vaccination m'ont pas ce sera plus
valide et je vais devoir me faire
vacciner si je veux qu'il soit réactivée
par monsieur le ministre je vous la vous
je ne suis pas très motivé les experts
constatent tous que le surdosage a pour
effet d'augmenter les
ce que d'effets indésirables liés à la
vaccination et ne pas prendre en compte
cette possibilité qui est reconnu en
suisse à 5 km de chez moi m'interroge
vous voulez protéger nos concitoyens
mais vous exposer certains comme moi à
une augmentation des risques en les
obligeant à se faire vacciner alors je
vous demande juste ce qu'il me paraît
être du bon sens celui d'appliquer le
principe de précaution comme le font nos
voisins helvétiques qui ne sont pas des
novices en matière d'expertisé à ce tic
merci chers collègues la part ou alors
c'est nous pas son 175ème qui fait
glisser de monsieur chaize qu'il
présente mais on a besoin de ce ministre
les deux amendements que je vous
présente mon père était de façon
concomitante sont sur le même sujet le
premier en fait reprend exactement les
arguments qui ont été développées ma
part ma collègue l'interrogation qu'on
peut avoir sur le sujet c'est le fait
que effectivement nos amis suisses
utilisent cette notion sérologique pour
éviter donc la vaccination alors
j'entends l'avis d'experts qui
contredisent l'intérêt néanmoins je
souhaiterais que évidemment on est ici
un débat et que l'on puisse avoir des
arguments donc objectif le deuxième
amendement justement permettrait de
laisser la possibilité dans la loi au
premier ministre après avoir
éventuellement donc corrélés et
récolter des informations
complémentaires par le biais d'un décret
d'intégrer cette possibilité dans le
pass vaccinale je vous remercie si
monsieur chaize nous passons à l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
alors ça c'est vraiment une question
purement
biologiques et médicales et du haut de
mon incompétence je vais vous dire ce
que j'ai appris récemment mais je vais
vous le dire de manière brève parce que
je ne saurais l'expliquer suffisamment
précisément pour que tous les savants
qui sont parmi nous puisse le corroborer
en fait quand vous avez été malade vous
avez peut-être des anticorps mais ces
anticorps ne disent rien de votre
capacité à résister aux formes graves de
la maladie si vous êtes deux nouveaux
infectés j'ai compris ça et du coup
l'ayant compris et je crois que ça n'est
pas matière à controverse je crois que
ça c'est une ça fait partie des choses
qui sont scientifiquement et
médicalement établi il est entendu
d'ailleurs parmi vous plusieurs
collègues qui ont la chance d'être
médecin qu'ils ont corroboré l'esprit
tant dans le détail donc ça c'est
certain et puisque c'est certain mes
chers collègues on ne peut pas s'appuyer
sur ces examens sérologiques pour
considérer qu'une personne est immunisée
contre les formes graves voire mortelles
du virus voilà ce que j'ai compris
alors notre avis la logique de ce que je
viens de dire c'est que notre avis est
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mais leur apportant philippe
bas a parfaitement expliquer les choses
je le redis brièvement il ya deux types
d'immunité votre système unitaire il a
deux modes d'action au moins il y en a
plus un mais à deux s'agissant du vaccin
il ya l'immunité dit immoral c'est les
anticorps en circulation qui sont
capables d'aller bastonner le virus de
reconnaître une cible sur le virus et de
l'empêcher de rentrer dans les cellules
ça s'est reflété notamment par le taux
d'anticorps dans votre sens pas que même
le taux d'anticorps dans votre sang dont
vous parlez madame la sénatrice est un
dard fait cela et à l'humilité dit
cellulaire c'est la mémoire conserver
parler vos cellules qui sont capables
lorsque vous êtes exposés au virus et
lorsqu'ils rentrent de fabriquer des
armes pour bastonner le virus et
l'empêché de se multiplier et donc des
pro b de provoquer une infection d'où la
prévention des formes graves si vous
faire une prise de sang qu'on va vous
six corps vraisemblablement où ils
avaient été exposés au virus où vous
avez été vaccinés ou les deux voudriez
vous d'ailleurs vous pouvez ne pas avoir
forcément un taux d'anticorps détectable
en soi tout en ayant était immunisé
auparavant ça peut arriver aussi or on
va pas proposer des vaccins advitam
eternam 5,6 widows aux gens parce qu'ils
n'ont pas un taux d'anticorps qui monte
à l'exception de table et je reviendrai
rapidement des immunodéprimés
et l'immunité cellulaire elle ne peut
pas la juger pas par une prise de sang
c'est pas un taux d'anticorps et votre
capacité des cellules à réagir en cas
d'agression on ne veut pas l'estimé or
je vous ai dit que c'est l'immunité
cellulaire qui rentrent en jeu en cas
d'infection pour éviter qu'elle ne
s'aggrave donc madame la sénatrice vous
pouvez avoir un taux d'anticorps parce
que vous avez été exposés au virus mais
si vous devez être réinfectées par le
virus
le taux d'anticorps ne dit rien de la
capacité de votre organisme à se
défendre et éviter donc une forme grave
une hospitalisation en réanimation ou
pire encore c'est ce que nous disent les
scientifiques y ait effectivement comme
le dit le rapporteur bas un consensus là
dessus peut-être peut-être un moment
donné dans quelques temps nous aurons
des études qui permettront de déterminer
un lien entre le taux d'anticorps et le
niveau de protection aujourd'hui ces
études ne sont ne sont pas validé ni par
la communauté scientifique nationale et
internationale croyez bien que il serait
beaucoup plus agréable pour tout le
monde si nous pouvions juste faire une
sérologie et éviter ainsi des passages
en sorte de vaccination toute la
logistique etc non pas pour les risques
du vaccin madame la sénatrice ya pas de
risque à vous faire vacciner mais pour
la logistique et star pour la simplicité
des choses ce serait beau nous pourrions
le faire mais aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas aucune certitude même aucune
indication sur typique la seule
restriction est assez pour les
immunodéprimés les grands
immunodéprimées un point est hélas les
vaccinés autant que vous voulez
clancy salut militaire ne garde pas la
mémoire et donc leurs cellules ont du
mal à apprendre et donc on peut faire
des tests d'anticorps particuliers qui
en dessous d'un certain niveau nécessite
qu'on le remette un traitement qui est
un traitement compliqué qui peut se
faire par perfusion pour éviter qu'ils
fassent des formes graves il en existe
nous traitons des milliers de malades
comme ça dans les hôpitaux dans les
services spécialisés donc un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
une ministre alors avant de passer au
vote j'ai plusieurs demandes
d'explications de vote a commencé par
madame jadis non
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je ne suis pas médecin mais
j'ai pendant 40 ans de travailler dans
ce domaine était responsable du
laboratoire au chu de guadeloupe je fus
calme et là dans la sérologie amiens
c'était un du secteur que j'encadrais je
vais soutenir
l'amendement de leur collègue d'excès et
tous ceux qui parlent de la sérologie je
suis moi même allé ici j'aurais fait en
guadeloupe pour noisy peut-être que j'ai
eus fut président d'une association eca
laboratoire que j'avais peut-être des
filons mais ici au sénat qui fait un
prélèvement de sérologie après la
vaccination eh bien j'ai un toit de
cette audi gm
2610 la nomme avec la technique qui est
utilisée par le laboratoire qui traite
nos prélèvements celle de 33,8 donc je
considère qu'il faut parce que la colère
elle demande le principe de précaution
et si la fois financer correctement la
recherche eh bien nous aurions peut-être
déjà eu des données concernant cette
problématique parce que c'est un vrai
sujet donc nous avons un système
immunitaire avec au début d'une
réflexion dirigée m
quand on a des ivg est aussi déjà
évidemment eh bien on considère que ce
n'est pas une époque flexion récente
parce que l'exigé m des clients
l'introduction de notre organisme nos
corps étranger eh bien nous avons
d'abord dirigé m ensuite des ivg et
d'exiger en aucune circonstance donc moi
je trouve que c'est amusé c'est abusé
que d'entendre ce que je viens
d'entendre donc je ne suis pas médecin
je ne suis pas professeur mais avec mes
ombres connaissance le trouve que les
questions qui sont posées aujourd'hui et
les réponses que j'ai entendu cela est
cohérent tout donc nous devons pour le
principe de précaution parce que prendre
plusieurs doses et en juillet déjà le
disais est ce qu'on va continuer avec
une deuxième une troisième quatrième
round 5e et que sais-je encore donc je
crois que nous devons prendre la mesure
des décisions que nous prenons ici et
pour cette question là je crois que nous
devrions justement voter ces amendements
pour le principe de précaution je vous
remercie
merci madame jasmin la parole et à
monsieur vie à la
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
je crois qu'il est plus là je voulais
juste poursuivre la discussion qu'on a
eue
dans un souci essentiellement de
d'explication
pour que les choses soient bien claires
puisque on est tous ici on a échangé
avec un sérum de collègues et on
s'aperçoit que on n'a pas forcément tous
la même interprétation de ce qu'on est
en train de voter c'est à dire un pass
vaccinale qui vient sanctionner un
schéma vaccinal complet le ministre l'a
dit tout à l'heure
yves il quand on verrai s'il ya besoin
d'une quatrième dose si et seulement si
le contexte le permet et c'est donc
aujourd'hui le schéma vaccinal c'est
quoi est ce que c'est bien deux doses
pour que ça veut dire que pour quelqu'un
qui entame son schéma vaccinal
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est bien dans
six semaines qu'il peut l'avoir ou
est-ce que c'est trois doses au
quelqu'un c'est au mois de juillet qui
l'aura première première question
deuxième question quand au bout de
combien de temps il n'a pas répondu à
cette question si on sait que c'est au
bout de trois mois qu'on a le droit ou
qu'on doit commencer à faire la
troisième dose combien de temps at on
pour faire cette saine dose avant que le
schéma vaccinal ne soit causé comme plus
comptait c'est à dire que le pass
vaccinale ne fonctionne plus quelqu'un
qui s'est fait vacciner le 30 octobre de
sa deuxième dose il a jusqu'au 30
janvier pour le faire donc il est ce
qu'il est bien considéré jusqu au 30
janvier du 15 au 30 comme ayant son pass
vaccinale et si oui jusqu'à quand at il
pour se faire vacciner avant que son
pass vaccinale ne soit plus réputé
complet et dernière question qui en lien
avec les amendements si jamais ils
attrapent locaux vides le 28 janvier est
ce que il doit quand même se faire
vacciner sa troisième dose avant le 30
janvier ou est-ce que cela malgré ce qui
vient d'être dit reporte d'une manière
ou d'une autre le
besoin de la troisième dose est ce que
vous pourriez nous apporter des réponses
précises à ses questions dans un souci
d'explication vis-à-vis de nos
compatriotes et pour qu'on puisse tout
ce savoir est bien clair sur ce
qu'implique ce pass vaccinale je vous
remercie
merci monsieur vial la parole et à
madame lassarade
merci madame la présidente
ces histoires d'anticorps dont on parle
là depuis maintenant plusieurs dizaines
de minutes je crois que le fait de doses
et aux sénateurs lors de la prise de
sang général à tout le monde les
anticorps anti coït ça induit une
confusion assez parfaite
comme comme médecins nous utilisons les
taux d'anticorps pour savoir si un
malade a été infectée ou pas tout
simplement mais c'est une notion plus
qualitative que quantitative dans la
quantité d'anticorps n'en fait aucune
importance dans la dans la défense qui
est important ce savoir s'il ya des
anticorps ou pas une fois qu'on ya 10 à
ceux qui comptent comme l'a expliqué
monsieur véran c'est l'immunité
cellulaire et c'est celle là qui nous
protègent la vie de nombreuses formes du
grenat virus on sait pas si ça nous
protège toujours pour l'instant oui
vis-à-vis de nos micros mais le plus sûr
au point de vue protection c'est bien
cette immunité cellulaire
l'immunité par anticor c'est beaucoup
plus
contestable et ça na pas dans ça n'a pas
d'intérêt en fait
même si maintenant
merci madame lassarade la parole et à
monsieur réchappe
merci madame la présidente madame un
ministre mes chers collègues je ne suis
pas médecin je suis docteur mais endroit
alors excusé je ne vais pas pouvoir
m'exprimer longtemps sur le plan
scientifique médical mais je dois dire
très franchement que je comprends pas du
tout cette
différenciation entre deux types
d'anticorps
d'alors que comme nous l'a indiqué
monsieur le ministre il y à un type
d'anticorps dont il a prononcé
le nom qui bastonne c'est le terme qu'il
a utilisé le virus
s'il bastonne si ces anticorps basten
léger russe le virus ne peut pas rentrer
on éclaire donc on dit après qu'il ya un
deuxième type d'anticorps qui va éviter
que vous soyez trop malade mais s'il
peut pas rentrer comment je peux être
malade bon je sais moi c'est
certainement béotien et mais j'essaye du
j'essaye de comprendre voilà moi je
voudrais simplement dire une chose c'est
quand je suis passé ici au cabinet
médical pour me faire doser les
anticorps
lorsque j'ai eu le résultat le médecin
m'a dit oh la la allez tout ce que vous
avez comme anticorps le virus n'est qu'à
bien se tenir
et quand je vous assure je n'ai pas
inventé ça n'a qu'à bien se tenir et
quand je dis je dois me faire vacciner
mais non ça sert pas ça s'est il ya
plusieurs mois à ces deux là où l'autre
l'acsa l'autre médecin vient donc très
franchement lorsque j'entends le
discours de madame drexler je me dis est
ce que est ce que franchement c'est un
discours qu'on qu'on peut ne me convainc
qu'on ne doit pas respecté et puis alors
si vraiment on ne doit pas de respecter
ce discours là ça veut dire que les nos
amis suisses vraiment ils sont très très
très mauvais très très très mauvais
alors autant leur écrire leur dire tout
de suite etc mais franchement
franchement il ya des choses que moi je
peux pas entendre donc voila moi si j'ai
des anticorps je trouve que fectivement
que j'en paye de malades on me l'a dit
tu vois pas pourquoi je dois en plus me
faire vacciner je vois pas pourquoi en
plus je le vois aller chercher etc etc
donc je voterai ces amendements parce
que je suis mais aussi un
merci la parole est à monsieur chastain
la présidente madame le ministre mes
chers collègues donc j'ai voté tout à
l'heure effectivement contre la bande en
cinq ans craint car effectivement cet
amendement était quand même fait pour
supprimer le pain se vaccine halle et
non faire un test de plus dans certains
établissements publics ciblés comme les
ehpad où il ya des personnes très
fragile et qui pourraient être
contaminés par des personnes vaccinées
qui viennent les voir et mais qui sont
effectivement qui ne savent pas qu'elles
sont contagieuses l'amendement de 90 est
une suppression du pass vaccinale par un
autre biais tuer le taux d'anticorps
alors nous sommes nous savons maintenant
que les anticorps
globalement chute beaucoup plus
rapidement que prévu notamment après
trois mois alors je reviens pas sur les
explications techniques ont été données
par le ministre et madame latéral mais
ce vaccin et fiable il ya très peu
d'effets secondaires dans mon
département il ya eu beaucoup de
vaccination j'ai pas vu d'effets
secondaires importants il est donc tout
à fait est nécessaire de ne pas d'oser
des anticorps mais faire
systématiquement un rappel ce sont les
études réalisées qui nous prouve cela et
c'est nécessaire
donc pour booster effectivement
l'immunisation et protéger la personne
vaccinée mais c'est protéger aussi la
population car la contamination
des personnes vaccinées n'est pas lunel
est possible mais est très diminué donc
je ne voudrais pas ces amendes
vous avez la parole
merci adam la présidente alors je
voterai aucun des amendements le premier
parce qu'il revient sur le pass
sanitaires sur le pass vaccinale et il
remet le pass sanitaire voilà et
comptent quant aux deux autres alors
la science aujourd'hui les dernières
données enfin les données scientifiques
il est impossible de corréler en fait le
taux d'anticorps par rapport à la
protection c'est un fait qui est
scientifiquement établi et en gros il
sert à rien de faire des dosages
d'anticorps à la population de manière
générale pour se demander si on doit les
vacciner ou pas les vacciner et comme
disait madame la salade faire un taux
d'anticorps ça peut dire ben tiens vous
avez été soumis au virus vous avez des
anticorps certains en développeront plus
ou d'autres mais ça en aucun cas sa
double i7 ce taux d'anticorps ne peut
pas lier contrairement à l'hépatite b
d'ailleurs où on sait qu'un tel à un
certain taux d'anticorps on ne vaccine
pas concernant le clac au vide 19 il est
impossible de faire ce lien entre le
taux d'anticorps et le vaccin tout cas
c'est la science aujourd'hui qui nous le
dit donc moi je voterai contre apprécié
on peut tous se lancer dans des courts
d'immunologie qui sont excessivement
compliqué moi je suis médecin
généraliste je suis pas immunologue mais
en tout cas voilà les la science là
dessus je suis absolument persuadé que
ce taux d'anticorps ne doit même pas
être dosé de manière systématique de
nouveaux traits contre ces deux
amendements tout en comprenant les
questionnements qui puisse avoir dans
cet hémicycle merci la parole est à
monsieur chaize
la présidente en fait j'ai pas eu toutes
les réponses à mes questions
la première réponse que j'ai pas eue
c'est pourquoi en suisse on utilise en
fait la sérologie est la deuxième des
questions c'est que il me semble que
ceux qui ont contracté le clac au vide
ont été dispensés de la deuxième dose ça
veut bien dire que quelque part il ya
quand même un effet et là non plus je
n'ai pas de réponse et je souhaiterais
vraiment avoir la réponse à dessus et au
pire je répète par rapport à mes
propositions d'amendements laissons au
moins dans le texte et dans la loi la
possibilité de le faire en laissant au
premier ministre le fait de pouvoir
déclencher l'opération
merci monsieur chaize ray parole et à
monsieur houpert
la mena présidente monsieur le ministre
chers collègues j'ai beau
madame ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
beaucoup aimé les arguments de madame
jasmin dessinatrice jasmin j'espère que
son prénom victoire portera chance à ces
trois amendements avant de fréquenter
cet hémicycle j'ai fréquenté des
hémicycles de médecine donc je vais pas
vous faire de cours de médecine mais
dans les hémicycles de médecine la seule
chose que j'ai appris c'est le doute
et moi je me pose des questions quand je
vois un pays comme la suisse où il n'ya
pas que de l'argent tous les
laboratoires ont leur siège social en
suisse et je pense que les lobbyistes de
ces laboratoires ont influencé les
parlementaires suisses qui ont décidé de
faire impasse sérologique donc je je
voterai là demain l'amendement de madame
drexler
il monsieur ou faire la parole et à
madame rex clair
merci alors ce que je voulais dire c'est
que vous savez moi aussi je suis
vraiment très intriguée par parce ce
taux a j'en parle aux médecins qui sont
autour de moi et je peux vous dire que
chaque médecin que j'ai rencontré à qui
j'en ai parlé un avis différent et ceux
qui doutent à ceux qui ont des doutes
sont beaucoup plus nombreux que que les
autres alors ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que je ne demande pas une
suppression du pass vaccinale c'est une
dérogation je demande une dérogation 1
comment on en a voté hier là je veux
dire moi je me retrouve avec un taux
d'anticorps qui est supérieur à la
limite supérieure
des anticorps et je devrais me re faire
vacciner je veux dire ça c'est juste fac
au jeu c'est juste du bon sens c'est
juste impossible de 2,2 de faire ça je
ce que je voudrais ajouter aussi c'est
que en suisse vous avez des sociétés
comme novartis comme roche qui
produisent eux mêmes des vaccins toutes
sortes de vaccins depuis des décennies
et c'est ce pays-là qui a décidé
d'appliquer le principe de précaution
donc vraiment je vous demande je vous
demande tous instamment de voter pour
cet amendement parce que je crois que
c'est très important
merci eh bien écoutez il n'y a plus de
demandes d'explications de vote je vais
donc soumettre aux voix le 90 rectifié
terre peut présenter madame drexler qui
a reçu 2 est favorable de la commission
et du gouvernement
pardon
si le ministre souhaiter s'exprimer et
l'oci sollicite
donc je vais mettre aux voix la maman
qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
175 rectifié biche 15,2 avis défavorable
mais moque même vote qui n'est pas
adopté de 181 rectifié bis deux avis
défavorables même votre il n'est pas
adopté nous passons 49 rectifié quater
et si madame noël qui nous le présente
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre dans sa grande sagesse le
législateur avait prévu à l'article 1er
de la loi du 31 mai 2021 de sanctionner
d'un an d'emprisonnement et de 45000
euros damende le fait d'exiger d'une
personne la présentation d'un résultat
d'un examen de dépistage virologique ne
concluant pas à une contamination par
l'e.coli d'un justificatif de statut
vaccinal concernant le coc vide ou d'un
certificat de rétablissement à la suite
d'une contamination par le co lead en
dehors des cas prévus par la loi dans
une démocratie la liberté est la règle
la restriction exception or il est
particulièrement surprenant et même
inquiétant de constater que le présent
texte prévoit la suppression de cette
sanction l'application des mesures
restrictives de liberté doivent être
strictement encadré et énumérés par la
loi et le règlement et tout excès de
zèle doit donc pouvoir être sanctionné
merci madame noël
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur pour la
vie de la commission
je suis désolé madame noël mais votre
amendement ne dit pas ce que vous voulez
lui faire dire
cet amendement en réalité tel qu'il est
rédigé à un effet juridique unique qui
est de soumettre les établissements de
santé à la présentation d'un pass
vaccinale je crois pas que ce soit ce
que vous vouliez non non j'ai bien
compris ce que vous voulez mais je vous
assure que sur le plan logistique c'est
exactement ce que l'amendement dit vous
savez je reconnais que c'est très
compliqué parce que nous travaillons non
pas en écrivant une nouvelle règle mais
nous faisons des membres de phrases qui
se greffe sur d'autres membre de phrase
que nous modifions et il y à une erreur
de rédaction de ce point de vue là qui
n'est pas rattrapable pendant notre
débat pour cette raison je vous demande
de retirer votre amendement il n'a pas
le sens que vous voulez lui donner j'ai
très bien compris ce que vous voulez
faire mais c'est parce que vous faites
en réalité sur le plan strictement
juridique delà de la rédaction juridique
de votre texte donc ou bien vous le
retirer ou bien nous donne un avis
défavorable
on va d'abord 30 à ce procédé à l'avis
du gouvernement madame noël après je
vous laisse la parole rapporteur
défavorable défavorable madame noël
alors je pense qu'il ya eu une erreur
peut-être par rapport au fait qu'on
l'avait rédigé à l'époque où on s'était
basés sur le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale qui a probablement été
retouchée par la commission et donc
qu'il ya peut-être eu un décalage en
tout cas ça concernait un alinéa qui
prévoyait de supprimer le e de l'article
1er de la loi du 31 mai qui prévoit
précisément cette sanction donc moi je
m'étonne un petit peu voilà
merci madame et noël
il est maintenu les rockeurs il est
retiré monsieur dire si vous voulez au
prochain à maman je vous donnerai la
parole
donc il est retiré nous passons aux 135
cm brulin pardon qui met réseau verizon
mais madame la ministre chers collègues
cet amendement vise à exclure la
pratique sportive de la présentation
d'un passé je dirais qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs sanitaires ou vaccinale je
pense que tout le monde et
particulièrement convaincu ici qu'il ya
un certain nombre de comorbidité qui
sont liés ou qui peuvent être liés en
tout cas à l'absence au manque de
pratique sportive et ex aequo morbidité
sont évidemment un facteur aggravant
dans le cadre du coc vide on sait aussi
que la pratique la ja ja aborde un
aspect préventif mais on sait aussi et
on a fait des auditions là dessus que la
pratique sportifs y compris actuellement
est un atout pour lutter contre le coc
vide et on sait également que notamment
parmi les jeunes puisque c'est eux
particulièrement qu'ils sont concernés
puisqu'ils sont aujourd'hui bien
évidemment les moins vacciner
la sédentarité a effectivement gagné du
fait des confinement notamment et donc
nous vous proposons d'adopter cet
amendement je me souviens qu'en octobre
dernier notre chambre c'était honoré
d'une disposition un peu similaire à
l'initiative de notre collègue savin qui
exempté d'opa sanitaires la pratique
d'une activité sportive c'est un peu le
même principe que nous vous proposons
d'adopter aujourd'hui et puis il s'agit
de remettre un petit peu de cohérence
aussi et ça n'est jamais du luxe par les
temps qui courent parce que en l'état
des pratiques sportives s'exerçant dans
des établissements relevant du public
vont être soumises à certaines règles
d'autres dans d'autres règles et on
imagine que par exemple dans des
compétitions on va rassembler des gens
qui ne font pas soumis aux mêmes règles
d'entraînement ce qui évidemment
compliqué je ne parle pas là des
compétitions internationales et je crois
que il est incompréhensible qu'on
permette à des enfants et des
adolescents d'après d'avoir une pratique
sportive dans le cadre scolaire et puis
dans le même lieu dans le cadre
associatif ou d'un club sportif que ce
soit soumis au pass vaccinale un peu de
cohérence ne ferait pas de mal merci
merci madame brulin monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente mais justement au
chapitre de la cohérence nous avons déjà
refusé hier un amendement analogue au
titre de notre refus de l'effeuillage de
l'artichaut si on fait l'énumération de
toutes les activités pour lesquelles on
retire l'obligation du pass vaccinale à
la fin il n'y a plus de passes vaccinale
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
dire que le sport est une activité
nécessaire et qu'elle contribue
d'ailleurs à tonifier l'organisme pour
résister contre les infections il faut
absolument l encourager ce qui n'empêche
pas qu'on le pratique avec le pass
vaccinale quand on a plus de 18 ans car
il ne s'agit je le rappelle puisque nous
avons exonérés du passé vaccinale tous
les mineurs de moins de 18 ans que le
le pass vaccinale pour les adultes alors
hier on a eu les sports déjà vous avez
dit non vous pouvez pas changer d'avis
toutes les dix heures nous avons eu les
lieux culturels vous avez dit non nous
avons les bibliothèques et les
médiathèques vous avez dit non nous
avons eu les musées vous avez dit non on
peut imaginer beaucoup d'autres
activités pour lesquelles on pourrait se
poser avec des arguments tout aussi
pertinents la question de l'exonération
du pass vaccinale et de ma les cafés les
restaurants les cinémas les salles de
spectacle pourquoi pas merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre
vous le suivez sur l'antenne de public
sénat depuis 16h45 le sénat examine ce
projet de loi dit un de passes vaccinale
l'examen a commencé hier et s'est
poursuivie tout l'après midi vous le
suivez donc en direct depuis 16h45 qui
reste environ
98 amendements à examiner avec cet après
midi des débats sur l'efficacité même
des vaccins ou encore de l'intérêt du
pass vaccinale ou encore il ya un
instant sur ces tests des anticorps avec
des sénateurs qui sont sceptiques sur la
vaccination et qui sont très mobilisés
en séance ce qui ralentit énormément
l'examen de ce projet de loi qui est un
peu en train de patiner en ce moment à
léonie rendra plus tard dans la soirée
sur public sénat mais avant cela on va
retrouver thomas hugues bonsoir thomas %
sully qui vont être encore question la
crise sanitaire dans votre émission
évidemment bonsoir quand on vous
retrouve un peu plus tard
dans la soirée évidemment poursuivre le
vote des sénateurs en direct sur public
sénat effectivement puisque on va parler
notamment de la grève qui promet d'être
suivie demain dans l'éducation nationale
on va beaucoup parler de la crise
sanitaire dans cette émission séance
publique tout de suite
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous sens
public votre rendez-vous de débats et
des analyses sur public sénat 90 minutes
pour décortiquer l'actualité et les
mutations profondes de notre société
avec comme tous les soirs trois temps
forts un débats d'actu pour commencer la
grève qui promet d'être suivie demain
dans l'éducation nationale syndicats et
parents d'élèves réunis pour protester
contre le protocole sanitaire mis en
place depuis la rentrée et en toile de
fond le bilan du ministre jean michel
blanquer entrée en question les
électeurs ont la parole c'est une
rubrique vous propose tous les soirs
avec un reportage au coeur des
territoires pour mettre en lumière vos
attentes autour d'un thème de la
présidentielle ce soir mobilité et
ruralité à sornac c'est une petite ville
de corrèze dont le maire à
municipaliser la station-service
l'essence est un service public et puis
troisième temps fort notre débat
volontairement décalée de l'actualité
portera ce soir sur les agressions
contre les élus + 47 % sur les onze
premiers mois de 2000 21 les chiffres
sont inquiétants deux élus témoigneront
tout à l'heure et puis nos experts
sociologues et politologues analyseront
le phénomène
mais d'abord donc la grève des
enseignants ou comment arriver à cette
situation paralyser un service public
majeur en plein pic pandémique cécile
fiction poids lourd du gouvernement jean
michel blanquer serait-il en train d'en
devenir le maillon faible depuis la
rentrée 2022 le ministre de l'éducation
nationale pays les revirements sur le
protocole sanitaire à l'école en une
semaine le gouvernement a revu trois
fois sa copie ce qui a suscité une
déferlante de critiques contre lui et un
appel à la grève jeudi des enseignants
conséquence c'est le premier ministre et
non jean michel blanquer requis est
monté au front et annoncé les dernières
simplification lundi sur france 2 j'ai
entendu les inquiétudes qui s'expriment
de la part des parents d'élèves des
enseignants des directeurs d'école et je
suis venu ce soir vous apporter leur
apporter un certain nombre de réponses
et de simplification une intervention
perçu comme un camouflet dans les rangs
de l'opposition de l'assemblée nationale
humilié pour les parlementaires de
droite il est appelé à la démission par
la gauche mais le porte parole du
gouvernement l'a sur le ministre a le
soutien de l'exécutif il ya eu des
difficultés depuis le début de cette
crise
et donc il ya une solidarité évidemment
entre les membres du gouvernement que
des décisions qui sont prises sont
prises de manière collégiale
je redis évidemment notre soutien au
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
ce contexte cet après midi au sénat
interpellé à quatre reprises lors des
questions d'actualité il a défendu une
école ouverte mais n'a pas échappé aux
critiques des sénateurs qu'elle avait à
tout cela parmi les causes une qui vous
incombent et à bout seul celui de la
gestion solitaire rejetant tout dialogue
faisant apparaître le bloquer rythme
pour ce qu'il est un autoritarisme
esseulé impliquant largement l'étrange
défaite dans lequel sombre ce
quinquennat en matière d'éducation avec
75% de grévistes prévu et la moitié des
écoles fermées la mobilisation de demain
risque de fragiliser encore davantage le
ministre
la stratégie du gouvernement à l'école
est le bilan que généralement du
ministre jean michel blanquer revoilà le
thème de notre débat je vous présente
mes invités tout de suite christine
rouzioux bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur émérite en virologie à
l'hôpital necker sophie bénédicte et
bonsoir secrétaire adjointe du snes fsu
et les enseignants du secondaire erwan
balanant bonsoir vous êtes député du
finistère vous êtes membre du groupe
modem au sein de la majorité
présidentielle vous avez signé au tout
début de cette année une tribune avec un
millier de personnalités ils ont un plan
à réunir emmanuel macron pour que la
révolution de l'éducation et de
l'apprentissage se poursuit voilà les
thèmes que vous aviez employés avec nour
duplex albert est nous qui rédacteur en
chef du service politique du figaro
bonsoy albert dénoue bienvenue en sont
évidemment matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique est à mes côtés
bonsoir
mathieu christine rouzioux le vrai pour
commencer avec vous faire un point sur
la phase de l'épidémie on bat chaque
jour un nouveau record en nombre de
contaminations est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on a un peu beaucoup je ne sais pas
perdu le contrôle de la situation oui
pour moi on a pu le contrôler à
plusieurs titres c'est-à-dire que tous
les positifs se font face et on a pas on
n'a pas exactement le nombre de positif
réellement généralement on estime qu'on
ne peut multiplier quasiment par deux
les chiffres que l'on trouve les tests
sont hygiénique
sont bien répertoriés mais les autotests
ne le sont pas donc on a quand même un
certain nombre de deux d'indicateurs qui
sont absents il ya 3 % seulement des
autotests qui sont qui sont rentrés dans
le système du ministère la santé et en
vain vert
la digue très grandes difficultés à
confirmer un autotest positif par pcr
les gens le font plus ou moins bien je
trouve les français relativement
responsables ils savent positif il faut
intentions mais de là à les déclarer à
les rechercher un test pcr par contre
oui certains vont comme ils vont quand
même pour savoir négativité mais à ce
moment là c'est pas enregistrée comme
telle donc on n'a pas les bonnes données
ça c'est clair mais elles sont
faramineuses en face et cette explosion
enfants adultes jeunes enfin voila c'est
mais là le fait est que la vaccination
joue vraiment bien son rôle et on n'a
pas pas beaucoup d'hospitalisation du
fait de cette vaccination c'est quand
même le point ce traitement positif
c'est un point positif est alors parlons
d'un terme il y en a peut-être un autre
c'est l' agence européenne du médicament
qui disait aujourd'hui que le monde va
peut-être un sortir de la phase
pandémique grâce à ce variant omikron
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement en fait enfin moi je parle
pour la france
l'immunité collective quand même en
train de se développer parce que tous
ces personnes affectées clairement
acquiert une immunité alors le vaccin
c'est juste l'immunité contre
l'extérieur du virus alors que quand on
attrape l'infection là on a on développe
une immunité globale non seulement
contre l'extérieur du virus mais contre
les protéines internes et là ça met en
jeu plusieurs systèmes dans la mémoire
immunitaire à la fois le la réponse
anticorps est à la fois la réponse
cellulaire et donc c'est une réponse le
composite un peu plus qui va qui va
compléter un la l'immunité vaccinale
donc on va renforcer et avec une limite
et hybrides chez un certain nombre de
personnes évidemment notre très grande
angoisse c'est cette explosion
d'infections virales chez les non
vaccinés ces vagues aussi pied passe au
travers là et là chez eux le risque de
formes graves et nettement
nettement supérieur à celui des vaccinés
donc là on est pas on a un mauvais
message en ce moment en disant ça va
c'est un nouveau virus il est moins fort
excès il est pas si moins fort que ça
élite eu malheureusement y tue et on
parlera notamment du cas particulier des
enfants avec avec vous tout à l'heure
donc l'économie elle galope on l'a bien
compris et le protocole de gestion de la
crise fait craquer les enseignants et
les parents d'élèves appellent à la
grève pour demain très suivie par
exemple dans le primaire voilà ce qu'on
annonce selon le snuipp-fsu qu'est le
premier syndicat du premier degré 75%
des enseignants 50% des écoles fermées
sauf yves inédite et qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez pour demain dans le second deux
alors nous dans les collèges et les
lycées on n'a pas l'obligation de se
déclarer 48 heures à l'avancé donc on
n'a pas encore des chiffres bien
stabilisé mais là cet après midi au on a
commencé à avoir des retours de la part
des surveillants et des cpe c'est la vie
scolaire et pee qui sont en première
ligne notamment depuis dix jours pour
faire toute la gestion des absences et
des cas contacts et là on a des chiffres
de grévistes qui sont supérieurs à 60 70
% dans les vie scolaire avec donc des
des surveillants et des cpe qui sont
très mobilisés ça montre bien là aussi
qu' il ya un ras-le-bol dans les vie
scolaire ça fait dix jours que les a
aidé les surveillants les cpe essaye de
se dépêtrer tant bien que mal des
consignes qui arrivent des ordres et
contre ordres et c'est ça aussi qu'on va
dire que les cpe les surveillants vont
dire demain que nous aussi en tant
qu'enseignant on va dire demain parce
que je ne vous raconte pas comment ça se
passe dans nos classes depuis dix jours
ça devient ingérable on n'arrive même
plus à faire notre métier et même on est
mis en difficulté parce qu'on ne sait
même plus ce qu'il faut répondre à nos
élèves et on est dans une gestion
complètement chaotique où aujourd'hui
bah en fait ça ne fonctionne plus et ce
quelque part c'est terrible de se dire
qu'on se met en grève pour pour âme pour
essayer de se protéger pour protéger
notre santé mais aujourd'hui après vingt
mois d'épidémie le bilan idée là la
gestion aller chaotique et aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus fonctionner alors erwan
balanant c'est vrai que les parents
d'élèves de la fcpe appelle ou aussi
agréable soutien en tout cas cette cette
graine est ce que vous pouvez admettre
que ce protocole de cette rentrée-là
2022 même s'il a été revu même s'il a
été allégé c'est tout simplement une
erreur non je pense pas c'est compliqué
il veut pas dire le contraire moi je
suis j'ai une petite fille de 11 ans qui
au collège je vois bien que c'est
compliqué moi je suis en lien avec des
parents évidemment c'est compliqué pour
tout le monde compliqué pour les parents
c'est compliqué pour les enfants et
c'est peut-être la première chose qu'il
faut voir et c'est compliqué aussi pour
les enseignants pour les a aidés pour la
vie scolaire mais on a fait un choix on
a fait un choix de garder les écoles
ouvertes moi je je je gérais on peut
avoir cette fierté d'être le pays où ça
a été le plus ouvert pendant toute cette
crise si l'école était fermée est-ce que
vous pensez que ça serait pas encore
plus compliqué pour les parents et pour
les enfants pour les enfants c'est sûr
on le sait les pédiatres le dise le fait
quand les enfants vont pas à l'école
quand il rate des longues périodes
d'école c'est pas bon pour eux et on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui en
souffrent pour les parents c'est la
catastrophe parce qu'il faut s'organiser
on peut plus aller au travail donc vous
voyez que fermer l'école complètement
ç'aurait été une alternative en réalité
saurait et essorés eu un facteur dans
kick in man bien supérieure pour une
bonne partie des français donc on fait
un choix qu un choix difficile et moi je
comprends je comprends la tension je
comprends la fatigue des enseignants
déjà eu des des cpe parce que les
directeurs d'être des directeurs
d'établissements parce qu'ils ont une
pression c'est compliqué très compliqué
pour xavier référer aux années
compliquées pour les soignants il faut
pas oublier ça y est voilà un sûr vous
avez fait référence sont effectivement
au nombre de jours de semaines de
fermeture on a regardé on va chercher
ici alors on a trouvé des cif du début
de la pandémie jusqu'au mois de mars
2021 et
alors il ya une islande qui sur cette
période fait mieux que la france six
semaines si normalement ces 10 semaines
ensuite on à l'espagne 15 semaines
l'allemagne 24 italie 32 et or si on
sort de l'europe états unis 47 semaines
et l'inde cinquante et une semaine
albert et nous est-ce que je vais rester
sur cette question là sur finalement ce
qu'est la philosophie du gouvernement et
donc du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'école ouverte est ce que
c'est un c'est à m quand même au bilan
positif du gouvernement dans la gestion
sanitaire et scolaire de cette crise
tout à fait celle le gouvernement avait
aller cette ambition et surtout emmanuel
macron de présenter comme comme bilan
une école qui reste ouverte et la plus
ouverte possible ça c'est à mettre au
crédit au crédit de manuel da cruz et
mai et là on touche on touche tout le
problème c'est que les problèmes aigus
c'est que celui l'an il se dit bien se
heurter avec la réalité de la cacophonie
de ces derniers jours avec avec des
protocoles qui change trois fois en
quatre jours ça a été et donc et même
des gens michel blanc caire qui a été
présenté comme au début du quinquennat
serait ce que vous en rappeler c'était
la star du gouvernement on parlait même
de blank réalisations du gouvernement
tant il était présenté comme le ministre
qui a réussi c'est parce qu'il est à la
fois très technique il était politique
il venait de la droite et il a amené là
une partie de l'électorat
avec lui et donc ils apporter quelque
chose hélas depuis depuis en fait depuis
quelques semaines depuis quelques mois
il se trouve confronté à une montée en
puissance
dans son ministère même dans celle
d'ange ses administrés si je suis le
dire d'une teinte de révolte et la
cacophonie entraîné une exaspération
total on devrait bientôt l'image
l'hôpital public la l'éducation
nationale a touché a touché quelque
chose de très profond dans une
désorganisation adverse et
d'institutions pardon nous interrompre
mais on va revenir notamment sur le
bilan de jean michel bancaire en général
et mémé c'est non mais c'était
passionnant et ça et ça lance bien le le
débat pendant que vous parliez tout le
monde ne faisait signe pour pour
intervenir je sais pas par qui commencer
peut être par vous
alors - virologues personnellement
j'aurais pas prêt ouvert l'école ouais
moi je trouve que tu manges et vacances
quoi j'aurais prolonger les vacances dix
jours c'était pas dramatique pour les
enfants alors que là on est à plus de
500 milles enfants infectés faut quand
même voir les choses le bilan va être
assez terrible fumier les formes au
grave on va les compter dans quelque
temps il ya maintenant des formes
cliniques de pim ce qu'ils sont bien
définis trois quatre cinq semaines après
la l'infection les enfants peuvent faire
un syndrome inflammatoire important donc
il faut que les parents sachent 1 ce qui
peut arriver chez ces enfants affectés
qui les surveille bien et tous les dix
jours pour mettre en place des
protocoles pour mettre en place les
tests anti génie qui soit fait il ya des
tas de parents qui savent pas faire
s'était sentie gênée il ya des parents
qui sont quand même un petit peu
vraiment terrorisée à l'idée de de ce
protocole qui leur est tombée dessus
autant que aux enseignants donc je
trouve que la mise en place même qu'une
petite semaine aurait permis quand même
de voir que on est et on savait que
cette vague allait être un tsunami on le
savait donc c'est vrai que les enfants
aiment ils étaient mieux à l'école etc
mais là on était dans une période on est
dans une période très longtemps et c'est
un peu ce que disait albert dino erwan
balanant c'est que finalement la
stratégie d'école ouverte
elle était peut-être valable mais où
jusqu'à omikron quoi c'est ça il fallait
peut-être l'achat mais presque là oui ça
changeait quoi je sais pas at il à dire
jusqu'à début janvier j'attends bien
c'est fait il a dit au wall a choisi est
sûrement fauteuil discret mais là c'est
à dire exactement ce qui le sait facile
à dire ouais c'est facile à dire moi moi
j'ai discuté avec plein de virologues
ils me disent mes mom nous parfois on
donne un certain nombre de conseils
qu'on n'aurait pas donné trois quatre
semaines avant un nom je suis déjà alors
moi je les données de l'homme et toutes
les vacances mais voilà vous l'avez
donné toutes les vacances là dessus mais
il ya un choix et le choix de garder
l'école ouverte nous dit 10 jours c'est
pas beaucoup pour les enfants mais vous
vous rendez pas compte que ces dix jours
c'est dix jours ces deux semaines deux
d'école et deux semaines d'école quand
on est en sixième quand on est en cm2
c'est beaucoup de temps d'apprentissage
perdu et tous les parents n'ont pas la
capacité de s'occuper correctement de
donner des enseignants des enseignements
à leurs enfants moi je vois bien les
conséquences on verra les conséquences
les conséquences les pédiatres
aujourd'hui le dise et vous avez vu
l'exemple vous avez montré les états
unis 46 semaines de fermeture sur les
deux ans ça veut dire presque à tout à
fait sur les deux ans et jusqu'à mars 21
d'accord jusqu'à mars 21 mais vous vous
rendez compte 46 semaines de non
scolarisation ce que ça veut dire alors
l'école de la république c'est une
grande victoire je pense que vous le
savez où la passion que vous avez de
l'enseignement et tout l'intérêt et de
la vigilance que vous avez quels que
soient les gouvernements pour que
l'enseignement soit jamais délaissé
fermé s'est délesté l'école à mon sens
mais voilà après jeu
je vous tendait la perche 1 la
transition est toute trouvée sur la
question de l'école ouverte c on entend
beaucoup jean michel blanquer a à chaque
fois répondre école ouverte d'ailleurs
c'était même le titre de son livre à
quel point c'est son marqueur et pour
nous en tant qu'enseignants enfin il n'y
a pas de débat bien évidemment que
l'école elle doit être ouverte bien
évidemment que les collèges et les
lycées ils doivent être ils doivent être
ouverts et c'est vrai que cette capacité
à focaliser le débat sur bison
extrêmement binaire et coll ouverte aux
écoles fermées ou en tant qu'enseignant
pour nous c'est pas ça le débat le débat
semer la face à redon d'éternité donc
mais face à omikron est ce qu on pouvait
garder l'école ouverte sans mettre en
place un protocole en considérer que
c'est une usine à gaz qui est trop
compliqué il était impossible c'est
qu'il a fallu l'amendé mais est ce que
c'est possible sans protocole nous
justement ce qu'on a dit c'est que ces
écoles ouvertes avec les protocoles
adaptés avec la sécurisation adapté et
bien souvent jean michel blanquer air
s'est arrêté à l'école ouverte et à
chaque fois qu'on a dit me faut des
moyens de sécuriser l'école et la
protéger je vais juste terminée parce
que je vous ai laissé finir de protéger
les élèves et les adultes on n'a jamais
eu de réponses ou des réponses
extrêmement tardive ça fait quand même
vingt mois 20 mois qu'on demande des
masques chirurgicaux et jean et jean
louis alors merci jean castex a annoncé
il ya une semaine au bout de vingt mois
de pandémie alors je sais pas s'il faut
applaudir mais quand même au bout de
vingt mois de pandémie
notre employeur n'a pas été capable de
nous fournir des masques chirurgicaux on
avait des masques en tissu enfin il ya
les basques en tissu ou il me tombait
sur la bouche ils n'étaient pas adaptés
ça fait vingt mois on parle d'aération
qu'on parle de capteur de co2 on a
peut-être avancé de 5 mètres sur une
course de 100 mètres ouais et peut-être
que même les masques chirurgicaux sous
six mois sinon on joue les mieux
adaptées face à aux micros ne cessa 6
terminé or dans les questions de l'école
ouverte mais vraiment nous on souhaite
qu'elles soient ouvertes avec un
protocole adapté et j'entendais bah oui
l'école l'école ouverte c'est un c à
mettre au crédit jean michel blanquer
pardon mais c'est quand même nous qui
depuis 20 mois tenons les écoles les
collèges et les lycées entièrement deux
seules souvent seul au milieu des ordres
et contre ordres on s'est débrouillé on
a tenu quand on découvre au dernier
moment des annonces dans la presse et
d'abord dans la presse le lendemain on
est face aux élèves on est face aux
parents et on a tenu pendant 20 mois
sauf que là au bout d'un mois ainsi plus
possible de fonctionner comme ça moi je
dirais encore avec des tournevis pour
ouvrir nos fenêtres dans nos salles non
mais alors et le débat école ouverte et
alors là mais les passes huile
létourneau musée va ouvrir les salles
les débats salomon vous nous protéger et
comment vous protéger les élèves et au
bout de vingt mois la réponse à n'est
toujours pas arrivé c'est ça le bilan de
jean michel blanquer c'est un bilan que
voilà que vous faites que je vais pas
dire caricatural c'est votre vécu je
vais pas le juger mais le bilan c'est
c'est aussi d'avoir maintenu le système
à flot et c'est pas simple vous parlez
des fenêtres les fenêtres avec un
tournevis cesser les collectivités
locales qui sait ça c'est le rôle des
collectivités locales crise dont pas
l'état n'ait pas démissionné parce que
l'état l'a fait l'état a débloqué 20
millions pour les équipements et 20
millions pour les capteurs de co2 par
rapport à ça c'est pas décidé si si ça
suffisait vous faites le calcul pour les
capteurs à paris
j'ai fait une division par le prix des
capteurs vous arrivez à un certain
nombre de capteurs quand elle est en
place et un et ça c'est une avance assez
fine aide pour les collectivités mais
c'est les collectivités sont
responsables de deux de ces voix là
après on peut dire que on peut enlever
un niveau de décentralisation et que
l'état reprenne le dessus c'est une
solution aussi pourquoi pas mais moi je
vais reprendre en seconde on va avancer
un plomb n'a pas encore entendu
mathieu cas je suis sur plein de choses
à nous dire et je vais redonner à
paroles à albert pendant un instant mais
je voudrais aussi on va partir sur un
domaine peut-être un peu plus politique
sur les conséquences politiques parce
que cette grève elle offre aussi un axe
data cause opposant d'emmanuel macron
notamment tient valérie pécresse était
ce matin sur france 2 ce qu'on voit
c'est un désordre et un chaos généralisé
dans l'école et moi je ressens cette
immense souffrance d'à la fois de la
communauté éducative même si surtout des
parents parce que on ne sait pas si les
enseignants sont là on ne sait pas quel
est le protocole à suivre aujourd'hui
vous voyez bien que on maintient ouvert
c'est une fiction même les maires sont
objectés fermé on n'avait même pas
apporté les repas dans les cantines
parce que les prestataires d'europe à
eux mêmes non plus les personnels non
moi j'aurais eu une autre gouvernance
que celle emmanuel macron il faut pas
une présidence solitaire et autoritaire
qui décide tout seul et qui dit c'est
comme ça et pas autrement il faut réunir
les maires pour voir quelles sont leurs
problèmes réunir les chefs
d'établissement alors j'aurai certaine
elle était comme une année de l'équipe
de l'ecoute j'aurais pris le parti de
l'ecoute le manque de concertation ce
n'est pas un des thèmes de de votre
chronique mathieu vous allez nous en
parler mais d'abord cette grève de ma
caisse qu'elle traduit pour vous mais
moi la question qui me turlupine c'est
comment on en arrive en pleine vague
pandémique à se retrouver avec un
mouvement de grève qui risque de
paralyser l'éducation nationale demain
et bien sûr des raisons
circonstancielles crds des derniers
jours on vient à parler un trois
protocoles en une semaine une
communication défaillante et au final
l'impression si on est sympa d'une
adaptation en temps réel parce que cette
gestion de crise avait compliqué et puis
si on est moins sympa d'un gros
cafouillage une forme de mépris
gouvernemental ou non du fameux adage
l'intendance suivra et aussi sans doute
en toile de fond un contexte plus
politique celui de la campagne
présidentielle on sait que certains ont
des arrières pensées et que certains
n'hésitent pas à lui pas tout ça mais à
une forme d'instrumentalisation ya
surtout des raisons structurelles plus
profonde que sournoise plus révélatrices
j'allais dire qu'ils traduisent une
certaine vision des rapports sociaux par
le pouvoir depuis l'élection des modèles
macro
si jean michel blanquer on est là
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il a choisi une
stratégie de rupture avec les syndicats
enseignants alors bien sûr dans les
histoires divorce est toujours difficile
de savoir qu hier arrêtez de parler à
qui en premier et les torts sont
évidemment partagé mais comme il est
ministre c'est quand même lui même lui
le responsable de la situation manque de
concertation dialogue de sourds
consensus impossible depuis son arrivée
de rue de grenelle jean michel blanquer
a choisi de mener ces réformes de
l'éducation au pas de charge avec ou
sans les syndicats c'est à dire en fait
plutôt sans alors ça peut marcher si
vous décidez de passer ou de tenir bon
c'est pas la rue qui gouverne comme
disait l'autre quelles réformes tombe
d'en haut et la base se débrouille là où
la méthode pose problème c'est qu'à un
moment ça finit toujours par casser en
particulier en période de crise comme
avec cette pandémie et en particulier
quand après leur avoir marcher dessus
ben vous demander sous tellement vos
interlocuteurs de se montrer
compréhensif de se montrer patients de
faire preuve d'initiative le vertical
tout d'un coup on appelle à
l'horizontale et généralement ça fais
pas tu as travaillé est ce que c'est la
méthode blanc caire qui est mise en
cause non car il n'est pas le seul enfin
prenez un autre ministre eric dupond
moretti à la justice bell lui aussi est
en rupture de dialogue avec les
syndicats alors faut reconnaître que les
syndicats l'attendait au tournant le
jour même de sa nomination et lui aussi
mais se retrouve dans une situation et
tout ça pourquoi parce que l'exemple en
fait il vient d'en haut de la vision qui
a longtemps eu les annales macron des
rapports sociaux des corps
intermédiaires il avait théorisé en 2017
en promettant de passer au delà de tout
ce qui selon lui bloque l esprit de
réforme en france alors il ya la rente
politique la rente étatique la rente
syndicale tout accusé d'entretenir
l'immobilisme du vieux monde et lui à
coude ordonnance de décision solitaire
et de vote d'un parlement souvent aux
ordres il a tenté d'en faire fi il en
paye aujourd'hui le prix dans la rue
reste à savoir s'il en perd à demain oui
dans les urnes albert et nous quels sont
les risques politiques de
de la grève de demain pour pour le prêt
dans la république pour emmanuel macron
salon
c'est se couper d'une partie de la
population
et d'avoir donné l'idée que sa gestion
de la crise j'utilise beaucoup là dessus
pendant un temps on avait cru d'un cru
comprendre que le bac on voulait ne pas
être le président de l'as de la crise
sanitaire vous voulez sortir du coc ide
et rentrer en campagne avec d'autres tel
pour ça qu'il avait lancé la france en
2030 et donc il voulait sortir c'est de
cet univers là et là ils étaient
rattrapés avec au micro de la terre
rattrapé par la crise ils arrivent ils
retardent naturellement sur nanterre
campagne et est celle qui fête ses
crises de colère et cette crise s'est
dit déterminé à bien se heurter
complètement avec sa stratégie de
stratégie en vue de l'élection
l'élection présidentielle et jean michel
blanquer qu'il était qui a été présenté
comme j'avais dit tout à l'heure comme
comme la sarre ne l'est plus il intrigue
à l'elysée ce qu est ce qu on a appris
aujourd'hui alors que le président avait
le sentiment que donnait le sentiment
que dans cette crise il avait tout fait
pour avoir une école ouverte rester le
plus longtemps possible donner aux
parents la possibilité d'envoyer des
entrants l'école donner aux enfants la
possibilité d'être d'être instruits et
il se trouve avec un jean michel lambert
qui ont en totale contradiction avec sa
stratégie est halal alors même que dans
d'autres secteurs par exemple roselyne
bachelot elle alors qu'elle a elle a
connu les éléments de la culture est
connue d'un enfermement une boucle de
fermeture des fermetures beaucoup plus
longue s'en sortent beaucoup mieux et
pour emmanuel macron avoir avoir jamais
chien blanc caire dans son équipe c'est
aujourd'hui s'est présenté comme un
boulet donc car vialatte alami a dit
aujourd'hui le fait est qu'on le
souhaitait même fortement mais il
n'empêche que ça reste ça reste une d un
caillou dans la stratégie de lehman et
mâcon pour la présidentielle mais c'est
pas toujours bon signe quand un porte
parole du gouvernement annonce qu'il
soutient
un ministre erwan balanant je les dis
quand je vous ai présenté le 1er janvier
dernier vous avez signé n'hésitez pas
c'est alain loin de là il y avait 1200
membres de la communauté éducative des
citoyens engagés pour l'école un appel à
la réélection des manuels macro et je
cite de nouveau pour que la révolution
de l'éducation et de l'apprentissage se
poursuivent donc vous faites forcément
un bilan qui est pas du tout celui de
d'albert et doux pourquoi non mais je
crois que cris il faut il ya deux choses
à dissocier il ya cette période là d'un
mois de cette semaine de rentrée
compliquée c'est facile de taper sur le
ministre parce que tout le monde est
fatigué dans ce pays tout le monde on le
voit bien tout le monde est tendu tout
le monde en a marre de cette crise et
les soignants croyez que les soignants
ils font grève non ils sont là et c'est
eux qui souffrent le plus aujourd'hui de
gens qui ne se sont pas vaccinés par
exemple et voulait bien rappeler donc il
ya un état de fatigue général midi en
appeler à la responsabilité jampel pas
la responsabilité en revanche je pense
que le fair général alain gasc re pays
c'est un droit et c'est un bon droit et
souvent ça permet de faire passer des
messages et que les syndicats fassent
grève aujourd'hui c'est leur droit mais
et si on ne garde gardons raison par
rapport à la situation il ya une
situation de fatigue généralisée une
situation de fatigue généralisée
certainement chez les enseignants oui
oui oui mais si un logiciel fragilisée
dans un dans un contexte c'est quand
même ce n'est pas seulement un problème
politique il faut aussi trouver
quelqu'un sur qui taper en ce moment
parce que depuis le début et des
français vous le diront on a là une
trouve que le gouvernement assez bien
géré cette crise les sondages 57%
récemment 10 emmanuel n'y aurait pas de
président koré fait mieux qu emmanuel
macron 57% des français c'est quand même
pas rien donc il ya un moment donné
devant cette fatigue il faut trouver
quelqu'un sur qui taper et évidemment
c'est conjoncturel là on a une situation
tendue à l'école effectivement vous
aviez plus de tests ils sont arrivés
depuis aujourd'hui je suis passé dans la
pharmacie avant d'arriver ils étaient
les tests c'était marqué tests
disponibles voilà bon ça c'est un côté
puis de l'autre côté il ya le bilan des
quatre ans et demi presque cinq ans de
mandat et là-dessus - longtemps d'un
tous les meetings the national on nous
avait dit de l'éducation nationale
depuis très longtemps et ça sera le
premier je crois qu'il fait un
quinquennat entier c'est pas ça veut
dire quelque chose aussi et là tout est
là dedans je crois que on avait une
situation très compliquée on a rattrapé
un certain nombre de choses en a fait le
de doublement des classes on a fait un
certain nombre de réformes comme
parcours sud qui a été critiquée
aujourd'hui les parents et les étudiants
la trouve plutôt bien parce qu'il
préférait faire cette sélection que le
tirage au sort voyez il ya plein de
choses qui ont bien marché et c'est ça
qu'il faut et c'est ça qu'il faut
regarder ayant encore des choses à faire
et je pense qu'il ya des sujets ya la
question de la rémunération il faut pas
que la crise sanitaire obscurcissent le
france la vision du jeu de mail en duo
mini-bilan kiki attention noyau le dire
aux syriens tout n'est pas parfait
puisqu'on peut pas on peut pas on peut
pas rendre parfaite une école qui
n'était pas parfaite et qu'ils aient été
abaissées si l'éducation nationale on a
la chance d'avoir ça dans notre pays et
alors et si on ne parlerait pouvoir
répondre peut-être sur le fond mais
d'abord j'aimerais quand même reprendre
une
critique ou un aspect delà de
l'intervention de mathieu tout à l'heure
sur les arrière-pensées est-ce que vous
menez avec cette grève aussi un combat
politique contre emmanuel macron avec la
présidentielle en ligne de mire donc sa
une une organisation syndicale on n'est
pas un parti politique dont conduit là
pour défendre tout simplement les
intérêts les cours je vais quand même
faire de la politique c'est qu'ils ont
du syndicalisme nous on a pas on n'a pas
attendu la crise sanitaire pour porter
un jugement circonstancié sur la
politique qui est menée par par jean
michel blanquer vous parlez de faire de
la méthode blanc caire la méthode blanc
caire en vue là effectivement on a vu ce
que ça donnait même avant la crise la
crise sanitaire quand il a été question
par exemple de la réforme du
baccalauréat c'est quelque chose on a
expérimenté où on a vraiment subi la
méthode blanc caire qui consistait à
avancer comme un bulldozer est
absolument pas écouter ce qu'on disait
et ça c'est ça a continué pendant la
crise sanitaire parce que j'entends
parfois le ministre dira oui j'écoute
les organisations syndicales or on l'a
rencontré la semaine dernière oui par
exemple je lui pose une question sur la
rentrée les bus scolaires au mois de
janvier il me parle de la rentrée 2022
donc est ce que c'est ça le dialogue
social octobre 2000 22 septembre 2022
social donc c'est une méthode très
verticale très autoritaire et qu'il
utilise depuis le début parce qu'elle
s'inscrit effectivement dans une
certaine conception de ce que doit être
le dire rejoint 302 la question un peu
différemment sur le le branle cette
grève va la suivre demain évidemment
est-ce qu'elle pourrait durer parce que
là on est aussi dans la question de
l'enjeu de la présidentielle de l'impact
de cette grève sur l'opinion et pour le
l'avenir d'emmanuel mâcon donc comment
vous voyez la suite est-ce qu'elle
pourrait durer c'est violent c'est quoi
votre objectif on voit que la
mobilisation elle est partie pour être
très important pour la maîtrise toriques
avec évitement des taux de grévistes qui
sont très importants pour la suite vont
contrat le bilan demain soir a priori on
ne s'interdit rien pour la suite parce
que nous on a quand même un objectif
c'est d'obtenir très rapidement des
moyens de protection et de prévention
dans les établissements scolaires pour
qu'on puisse fonctionner c'est ça
l'objectif c'est qu'on se retrouve pas à
courir derrière les masques accouraient
berra les tests à s'arracher les cheveux
le matin pour savoir quel est le
protocole sanitaire qu'on va appliquer
et à enfin obtenir aussi un dialogue
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et obtenir une méthode de
travail qui soit respectueuse des uns et
des autres et après s'il faut continuer
pour obtenir ça ben on continuera et on
verra sous quelle forme mathieu au delà
des enseignants c'est peut-être
l'exaspération des parents que
l'exécutif scrutent de très près ou de
plus près on sait tous que c'est l'école
est un sujet inflammable d'une façon
tout le monde a un avis sur l'école
lourde a été utilisé à tort si j'ose
dire usagers et les laits ou parole
d'allah et puis et puis un million on
verra quand même de deux personnels
enseignants donc donc c'est un sujet
très compliqué et qui n'est pas au coeur
de cette campagne présidentielle il faut
le dire il ya certains candidats
contenter de le mettre en souvient de
propositions très critiquée d'anne
hidalgo de doubler les salaires de tous
les personnels en contact avec les
enfants ou la plus récemment celle
d'eric zemmour de remettre tout le monde
avec une blouse et de faire un grand
ministère de l'instruction publique
voilà c'est mémé sinon au delà de ces
slogans ou de seuil et de ses
propositions un peu chocs y a pas de
vraie réflexion sur la transformation de
notre de notre système scolaire c'est
comme l'hôpital au fond on est quand
même dans un moment particulier où on a
ses moments de tension ces moments
sociaux de
2° voodoo de ras-le-bol ou de colère et
puis quand on a l'occasion d'en débattre
quand on a que c'est l'occasion de
construire quelque chose des
propositions et ben il n'y a personne
derrière c'est souvent une question de
moyens qu'on vient vous allez mettre
mais vous allez m mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait d'hôpital et de l'offre de soin en
france mais de l'offre éducative il n'y
a pas grand effet d'ailleurs on en parle
et on en parlait lundi c'est peut-être
possible que cette crise qu'ovide par
écraser un peu tout tous les autres
thèmes et à nous frustrer nous elle
révèle aussi des systèmes entre c'est
vrai mais elle frustre aussi les
personnalités politiques - nous sommes
qui avons envie de faire des
propositions voit bien mois sur un site
je travaille sur un certain nombre de
sujets on voit bien qu'on n'arrive pas à
les enclenché dans le dans le dans le
spectre médiatique parce qu'il ya là
parce qu'il ya la crise et c'est
effectivement frustrant et c'est
pourtant des enjeux qui sont des enjeux
con qu'on doit débattre en moments de
campagne présidentielle parce que c'est
le moment où il ya des montées voilà des
sceaux d'idées généralement pas alors
les sens pour information on va pas tous
les jours centré l'émission autour de la
crise sanitaire et on va même chaque
jeudi sanctuariser un rendez-vous qui
s'appellera demandez le programme
où on va prendre les grandes thématiques
voilà majeur structurante du débat
politique pour les analyser on va
vraiment essayer d'être dans ce dans
cette promesse de recul sur les grands
thèmes de la de la présidentielle de
cette campagne et christine rouzioux je
reviens à la place des enfants dans
cette pandémie alors peut-être que vous
n'avez pas les mêmes chiffres mais moi
j'ai trouvé 400 enfants hospitalisés
dont 80 en réanimation un chiffre qui a
triplé en un peu moins d'un mois
voilà et
et la pédiatrie commence à sentir clem
mais alors exemple le sens du goût les
enfants que pardon du terme et qu'ils
étaient à risque non non c'est moi
forcément non les enfants à risque pour
le coup la vaccination
s'est relativement bien développé
relativement rapidement non là l'enjeu
c'est laval la vaccination des enfants
alors que pas du tout des 5 11 11 3 %
tamar sont pas bien du tout il ya eu les
vacances scolaires qui ont fait que les
enfants étaient dispersés effectivement
ça mais là justement avec ce désordre
dans l'école les parents qui doivent
tester les enfants qui reviennent qui
sont qu'à contacter enfin voilà on est
dans un désordre tels que les parents
trop de choses à gérer pour réfléchir à
cette vaccination je crois qu'il faut
dire les choses
on est loin de d'imaginer qu'il ya plus
de risques même si les signaux et de
l'afrique du sud est de l'angleterre
montrent que les choses sont en train de
de diminuer le pic est en train de
baisser chez nous on est plutôt en
plateau on n'est pas du tout encore au
pic et donc il ya encore un risque réel
au moins pour pour trois semaines qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire aux parents qui
hésitent à faire vacciner leurs jeunes
enfants que cette vaccination c'est un
bénéfice évident par rapport aux risques
de la maladie de l'enfant en fait le
c'est un bénéfice
vraiment important et et qui va en faire
une protection y compris sur
éventuellement un nouveau variant il
faut que la fal avec lynott la
vaccinologie c'est c'est de la
prévention alors évidemment je le
connais pas le nouveau variant mais il
peut être là en mars en mai en juin ou
en septembre si les enfants sont
vaccinés maintenant voilà on aura fait
de la prévention pour pour vraiment un
moment d'autant que la réponse vaccinale
chez les enfants est toujours très forte
et en plus c'est un tiers de doses en
face et voilà c'est une opportunité on
est dans un pays où on a accès à la
santé on a accès aux soins on a accès au
vaccin gratuitement alors que les
vaccins que les parents réfléchissent et
qu' il y ait un manque d'information
sans doute mais ça voilà le manque
d'information c'est les vacances et
cette rentrée je pense que là il faut
reprendre le flambeau et réexpliqué la
protection va être longue et les vallées
coronavirus il va y en avoir d'autres
voilà je pense que c'était important de
faire passer un message mais sur la
vaccination des enfants évidemment je
pense qu'il faut ici il faut y aller moi
est ce que j'avais quand même compris
des autorités sanitaires bon déjà ils
ont donné le go juste avant le pour la
vaccination des enfants juste avant les
vacances mais c'est mid100 mi-décembre
ensuite nagé on est à quatre ports il y
avait quand même un message qui était
donnée encore à ce moment là et toujours
par certains par les infectiologues en
disant protégeons d'abord les plus
fragiles et vaccinés en priorité encore
les 65 50 qui sont pas encore vaccinés
et après on ira vers les enfants et moi
je pense que vous avez sans doute raison
certainement plus que moi parce que
c'est quand même votre métier c'est que
c'est maintenant qu'il faut aller vers
la vaccination dès maintenant et
peut-être que c'est aussi un moyen de
répondre à la crise mais bien sûr sur
les sur à l'école et puis évidemment se
faufile inédite et je reviens puisque
faute de vaccination il ya cet enjeu
majeur de protection des enfants et des
du personnel de l'éducation nationale
qu'est ce que vous réclamez vous pour
être mieux protégés irait question des
masques à la question des capteurs est
ce qu'on peut être précis la question
effectivement des masques donc masque
sur pivot masques ffp2 si besoin il ya
la question des capteurs et de
l'aération des salles et la question
aussi de la politique de test dans
l'éducation nationale qui reste quand
même un espèce de grand trou noir de
cette crise sanitaire dans l'éducation
nationale dans les collèges et les
lycées on ne testent plus depuis des
mois c'est à dire que il ya eu une boîte
d'autotest distribué aux élèves de 6e
ont peut-être avant les vacances mais
pour le reste on n'est pas du tout en
mesure de savoir ce qui se passe dans
les collèges et les lycées de savoir
exactement à quel moment on va peut-être
casser certaines chaînes de
contamination il y aurait traîné c'est
forcément besoin d'affiner la question
de la politique des tests et d'avoir en
fait tout simplement des à la fois des
protections mais aussi des règles
lisible parce qu'aujourd'hui on a perdu
en lisibilité aux ce matin un élève qui
vient boire qui me dit mais pas qu'il
veuille voir qui me dit mais je suis
qu'à contacter qu'est ce que je fais
bayer les annonces de viande eu
forcément répondu les annonces de jean
castex lundi soir mais on n'a pas eu
d'information depuis donc on ne savait
pas lui répondit a besoin de lisibilité
aussi mathieu pardon j'ai juste une
question est ce que la règle la plus
visible et la plus protectrice proulx ça
serait pas de réclamer la vaccination
obligatoire présence ayant alors bien
sûr la question de la vaccination des
enseignants mais je rappelle qu'il ya
tout juste un an quand on commençait à
parler vaccination en france qu'on a
très vite dit il faut que les
enseignants soient prioritaires sur sur
la vaccination on la demandait dès le
mois de janvier on ne l'a jamais eue
mais là maintenant parle des
vaccinations obligatoires
en dépit des obstacles qui nous ont été
mis en sevice signer très rapidement et
aujourd'hui le taux de vaccination chez
les enseignants il est très élevé il est
de plus de 80 ans ils sont donc
aujourd'hui la question pour nous elle
est patent sur la vaccination alors que
vous avez qu'elles sont un public qui
est très majoritairement vacciner parce
qu'on connaît les enjeux que de
l'ensemble de la protection des collèges
et des lycées oui à la cabine médecine
en a on a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
publiée communiquer sur la vaccination
et pour nous c'était évident que les
enseignants devaient être prioritaire au
même titre que les soignants c'était
pour nous aimer mais c'est vrai que
l'obligation vaccinale est un fonds est
un gros sujet est d'ailleurs on va
communiquer ces jours ci l'académie
communiqué ces jours ci sur l'obligation
vaccinale essayé de pousser un petit peu
le le sénat pour responsabiliser faire
je trouve que c'est un devoir civique de
l'état en même temps qu on demande un
devoir civique oh non vaccinés de se
vacciner donc il faut que ce soit dans
les deux sens et que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités mais encore une fois on
est un pays où on a accès à tout enfin
fait faut quand même réaliser ce qui se
passe au sud et à quel point la carte de
vaccination au sud est pas et il n'y a
pas d'accès il n'y a pas d'information
c'est pas quel virus sont là enfin on
sait même pas le taux de mortalité
un des derniers pays comme madagascar
c'est catastrophique le virus circule
donc il faut quand même
utiliser les outils correctement et puis
et puis c'est vrai que ce vaccin n'est
pas parfait mais et qu' il faut
continuer et que la vie va être
continuer à être perturbé qu'il faut
continuer à faire attention le masque
etc et mais je trouve que dans
l'ensemble les français on était quand
même très responsable sur un certain
nombre de choses société et ça s'est il
faut le remarquer il faut il faut
soutenir ça mais mais le fait est que il
ya un moment où cette vaccination
obligatoire fin pour moi c'est voilà
c'est en irak cesse et c'est une chance
bon et on suivra effectivement vos
préconisations dans l'est dans les
prochains jours sur ce thème notamment
merci merci d'avoir participé à ce débat
mercier a bercé nous de nous avoir de
nous avoir suivi également jeu tous à
bientôt sur public sénat vous savez dans
cette émission on aime prendre du recul
prendre du temps pour analyser les
mutations de notre société et chaque
jour on vous propose un débat qui est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité
tout à l'heure on va revenir sur ces
chiffres donnés il ya quelques jours par
le ministre de l'intérieur on a
aujourd'hui plus de 300
dépôt de plaintes qui ont été faits par
des élus nationaux ou des élus qui
passent ce dans les médias on pourrait
appeler ça comme ça parce qu'ils ont
reçu des menaces de mort voilà 300
menace depuis début juillet ça vous est
arrivé aussi
vous en faites partie les violences
contre les élus avec le témoignage d'un
maire qui soutient emmanuel macron et un
sénateur et l'eire qui est menacée après
avoir ôté le passé ni terre ce sera tout
à l'heure dans ce sens public mais
d'abord on passe à notre rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole
les électeurs ont la parole chaque jour
les reporter de public sénat par ta à
votre rencontre dans les territoires
pour vous donner la parole pour
illustrer aussi un thème de la campagne
présidentielle
ce soit on parle ruralité avec la vie
des habitants de sornac on est en
corrèze 800 habitants et une station
service qui est gérée par la commune
c'est un service public en quelque sorte
bilan un dynamisme étonnant pour un
village de cette taille aux rêves états
jean-françois loge maire de jarnac
ici comme chez mes collègues à côté on
essaye de se battre pour avoir
l'ensemble des commerces les aider
autant qu'on peut et surtout garder et
faire venir de nouvelles populations sa
botte secrète c'est cette station
essence au sortir du village vous avez
deux carburants le gasoil et le sans
plomb 95 un détail pour certains mais
pour sornac ça veut dire beaucoup car
ici la voiture est indispensable
les transports en commun sont rares et
la ville la plus proche ussel treize
mille habitants est à 20 km alors il ya
12 ans quand l'ancienne station privée a
mis la clé sous la porte le maire a
décidé de la reprendre loin d'être
anodin ce choix a coûté 130 mille euros
d'investissement à l'inconnu le but
c'est bien sûr c'est de fournir du
carburant à la population et fournir aux
entreprises aux siens puisque c'est
quand même le gros de la clientèle sur
le passage en plus soyez ce soit avant
sur le passage pour la litière
rapidement elle est vraiment très bien
placé la station aux couleurs de la
commune est devenue un service public
géré par deux agents municipaux et les
prix sont très compétitifs car la mairie
ne prélève que 6 centimes de marge pour
assurer les frais de fonctionnement et
de mise aux normes résultat les tarifs
sont presque identiques à ceux pratiqués
en grande surface et les clients se
bousculent à la pompe moi j'habite la
commune de sornac et donc moi c'est plus
facile pour moi avons voulu mettre du
gazole ici donc c'est pour ça il fait
marcher le village donc tout simplement
du passage qui bénéficie aux commerces
de sornac comme ce garage automobile
située juste en face de la station des
gens
ils font leur plein donc baisse assez
intéressant pour nous parce que les gens
y viennent là sont curieux donc ils
viennent et pouvoir préparer des
voitures résultat le village de 800
habitants est beaucoup plus animée que
la moyenne pendant une boulangerie
pâtisserie
on a un brocanteur on à tabac journaux
on a une coiffeuse on a une agence
postale
on a une pharmacie
bien sûr et pour le moment dans l'ancien
bâtiment mais bientôt dans le nouveau
avait si on n'avait pas les stations
service il y aurait eu un manque à
gagner sur l'ensemble des commerces
bergeron avec les stations la mairie est
sorti de son domaine de compétence un
exemple de la france rurale qui se
réinvente pour ne pas disparaître
un autre exemple est des leçons
peut-être un peu plus générale aussi
avec patrice joly qui est avec nous en
duplex le sénateur socialiste de la
nièvre président de l'association
nationale nouvelles ruralités bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous étiez maire d'une commune de de
taille similaire
à sornac ouroux en morvan et vous aviez
vous aussi municipaliser la station
service alors j'ai deux questions
combien ça vous avait coûté fait pour
quel résultat alors select 2008 donc je
le retrouve tout à fait dans la démarche
des cellules journal c'est à dire les
efforts faits par les élus pour
maintenir de l'activité économique que
du commerce des services et favoriser
l'attractivité économique de la commune
effectivement ondes étaient les ordres
de grandeur était de l'ordre de 100 mio
je suis tout à fait d'accord d'elle mais
c'est ça il alla son service géré par la
commune avec une marge faire permettant
de couvrir les frais d'entretien
fonctionnement naturel avec des agents
communaux et j'ajoute eu des ald et des
élus municipaux qui met la main à la
pâte pour que ça fonctionne et pour
quelles raisons données en termes de
dynamisme économique est ce un
participant à nos semble c'était un
service par rapport à d'autres c'est à
dire que dans mon village par exemple le
camping municipal mais gérée par un
privé même chose pour les gendres et
d'autre même chose pour l'hôtel même
chose pour le gîte d'étape même chose
pour l'épicerie même chose pour le salon
coiffure même chose pour le gard à
chaque fois ce sont des privés mais avec
un immobilier porté par la collectivité
et qui permet de garder moi la même ce
même même situation que sort dingue
c'est à dire la première station service
et elle à 18 km de ma commune il fallait
absolument
lorsque le garagiste partent en retraite
décidé d'arrêter il fallait absolument
qu'on trouve une solution et donne tous
ateliers cohérence et maintient une
activité avec l'activité postale avec la
mise en place d'un cinéma rural en fin
de tout ça et en faisant avec des
finances qui sont bien numéro ou
d'imaginer plus tôt contre un comment
vous
vous analysez vous évaluer
l'action les propositions des candidats
à la présidentielle en matière de
ruralité alors on disait dans notre
débat précédent que la crise qu'ovide
écrase un peu tous les autres thèmes
mais qu comment vous quand par exemple
un eric zemmour voilà ce se place en
situation en dit je suis un rat des
villes mais va quand même en campagne à
la campagne comment vous analyser tout
ça enfin nouveaux décès depuis
maintenant un certain dan et dans le cas
de l'association que j'anime et qu'anime
également sur l'appel le parlement rural
français c'est de faire en sorte que les
questions rurales soit donc débat public
alors que au cours des dernières
décennies on était beaucoup sur les
problématiques métropolitaine c'est à
dire en fait considérons que la
concentration qu'elles soient
institutionnels économiques favorisent
est en fait nous favoriser dans la
compétition internationale on a vu que
aujourd'hui c'était pas le cas on voit
ce que représentent les la concentration
humaine qui fait que plus difficile de
gérer une crise sanitaire dans des
villes que dans que dans la guerre la
campagne et on envie d'être partie
prenante dans l'avenir du pays et l'on
veut surtout démontré que la la ruralité
apporte à la société française c'est la
fois son histoire son identité notre
perspective de dire nous sommes dans
notre temps nous sommes contemporain est
ce qui se passe nous sommes pas des
territoires du passé mais des
territoires d'avenir d'ailleurs les flux
que l'on constate de population gourde c
et l'ema l'évolution des marchés
immobiliers montre qu' il ya des
français qui est d'ailleurs à l'échelle
européenne les gens qui ont compris
effectivement qu'il y avait un autre
cadre de vie des possibilités de vivre
développer des activités à la campagne
et donc ça
ça va faire évoluer les les chiffres que
je vais donner tout de suite on dit 80%
du territoire mais seulement 30% de la
population
quand on parle de ruralité c'est vrai en
france et je crois à peu près la même
façon en europe est ce que ça explique
pour vous le fait que cette thématique
elle pas si souvent sous les radars deux
des candidats à la présidentielle c'est
la raison pour laquelle il fallait que
les bons chiffres et l'insee 10 à 20%
durant 80 % urbain et à force de travail
et surtout accompagné par des
universitaires des chercheurs et en
conjuguant nos forces on a réussi à
faire changer les modalités calculs de
l'insee qui aujourd'hui à des chiffres
qui se rapporte de l'insee européens et
que sa valeur au stade et qui indique
que le 30 % de la population est rurale
ce qui n'est pas exactement la même
chose et que 70% de la population est
urbaine et donc ça veut dire que dans la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
on doit avoir une part qui correspond à
ce que représentent nos populations au
moins mais aussi au service que l'on
rend à l'ensemble de la société
je parle en particulier la dépolluer
pollution de l'air de l'eau qui se passe
chez nous à travers la captation de
carbone notamment que nos territoires
offre et puis
l'alimentation de l'alimentation de
qualité en fait on pourrait multiplier
les exemples de ceux des apports de
l'eau territoire à la solitaire générale
or il reste quand même c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a des filles
population qui reviennent vers la
campagne pour acheter des résidences
secondaire ou principale il faut qu'on
dispose des services pour ça et je pense
en particulier dans le domaine médical
est la première préoccupation en matière
de mobilité et puis il ya surtout une
politique plus globale apportée sur les
territoires ruraux ils se sont très
impoli au cours de ces dernières
décennies avec la disparition
d'agriculteurs un nombre important
d'emplois industriels parce que ce sont
des territoires industriels aussi
historiquement et donc il y as besoin
même si aujourd'hui on a dans le débat
public et je pense que les gilets jaunes
ont contribué aussi à ça dans un débat
public à re réalité existe aujourd'hui
qu'un certain nombre de dispositions ou
des mises en place en cas d'un talent
d'un agenda rural français avec un
ministre dédié qu'on revendique elle il
faut aller plus loin pour répondre à ces
pneumatiques je viens d'évoquer non
seulement à l'échelle française
également à l'échelle européenne
merci beaucoup merci patrice joly je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur ps de la
nièvre et président donc de cette
association nationale nouvelles
ruralités seller tout de suite de notre
seconde et va dans ce sens public vous
le savez débat en profondeur pour
analyser les grands thèmes de l'élection
présidentielle ou un phénomène de
société ce soir la violence contre les
élus 300 plainte pour menaces de mort
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du passani
terre début juillet des agressions en
hausse + 47 % sur les onze premiers mois
de l'année 2021 les chiffres du ministre
de l'intérieur sont inquiétants jérôme
navier longue et impressionnante et un
contexte explosif qui inquiète les
violences contre les élus ont atteint en
2020 des records avec une hausse de
presque 50 % sur les onze premiers mois
de l'année et 1186 est lui pris pour
cible interrogé au sénat aujourd'hui
marlène schiappa a confirmé que les
parlementaires et les maires en étaient
les premières victimes
ce sont 160 deux parlementaires et 605
maires ou adjoints qui ont été victimes
d'atteintes volontaires à l'intégrité
physique et je veux dire que derrière
ces chiffres il y à des réalités des
vies et des 10 qui font vivre la
démocratie et je crois que défendre
l'intégrité des élus est fondamental de
débats oui la controverse oui la
violence la menace jamais le dernier
épisode date il ya à peine quelques
jours avec ces images terribles du
député de saint pierre et miquelon ciblé
devant son domicile par des opposants au
pass sanitaire au sénat depuis longtemps
on est mobilisé sur le sujet pour la
délégation aux collectivités locales il
faut désormais que chaque acte soit
reconnu et suivie de sanctions doit y
avoir une reconnaissance d'une agression
doit pas y avoir d'impunité
d'insouciance ou d'indifférence seriez
une agression il doit y avoir une
plainte il doit y avoir une réaction
être implacables pour moi c'est ça ça
veut pas dire qu'on va emprisonner tous
les gens commettent des agressions mais
il doit y avoir une nette réaction face
à la flambée des violences mais aussi
des menaces sur les réseaux sociaux le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand annonce sa volonté que
l'institution accompagne les députés qui
portent plainte et se constitue
systématiquement partie civile
une manière de les placer sous
protection de la république quelle que
soit leur couleur politique
et on analyse ces chiffres de violence
contre les élu-es une flambée inédite je
vais poser la question à mes amis tes
isabelle sommier bonsoir un soin à muse
est enseignante chercheuse en sociologie
politique à l'université panthéon
sorbonne et vous publiez violences
politiques en france de 1986 à nos jours
c'est aux presses de sciences po paris
jérôme bascher bonsoir bonsoir sénateurs
l air de l'oise vous avez vous même été
menacé vous nous raconterez comment
c'est le cas également de bernard denis
et maire de saint côme du mont dans la
manche qui étaient avec nous en
visioconférence vous soutenez emmanuel
macron depuis 2016 avait été victime
d'une agression votre domicile le mois
dernier
j'accueille également martial foucault
bon soin soit mis à nu professeur à
sciences po directeur du cevipof vous
avez publié sept en 2020 mère au bord de
la crise de nerfs aux éditions de l'aube
et matthieu croissandeau est toujours à
mes côtés évidemment vos témoignages
d'élus pour pour commencer je démarre
avec vous jérôme bascher qu'est que vous
est-il arrivé comme d'autres
parlementaires de l'oise moi je suis
parlementaire et là il ya des
parlementaires la réplique en marche
mais il ya exactement quatre députés
trois sénateurs qui nous avons reçu à
priori du même envoie une lettre en
disant avec une cartouche de 22 long
rifle qui est dit sur le pass
vous avez vous n'étiez pas présent voilà
à l'assemblée ou au sénat vous n'étiez
pas présent vous ne défendez pas les
libertés la peau de la prochaine sera
pour vous voilà
bon ça me perturbe pas plus que ça je du
sang froid sénatoriales si vous voulez
mais c'est allé plus loin pour nos
collègues députés d'appliquer en marche
pascal bois qui lui s'est fait cramer sa
voiture dans la nuit à son domicile
il a été réveillé par les pompiers des
mots explicites ont été
taguées sur son mur donc il ya des gens
pour lesquels ça devient beaucoup plus
sérieux mais je prépare lui aussi du
maire de verberie michel arnould qui a
été agressé plusieurs fois par sans
doute
justice fait son travail dans kate mais
par des jeunes qui s'adonnaient un peu
un trafic de produits stupéfiants
oui oui ça existe aussi il ya dix
ans chez eux en brûlant maisons et dont
ils peuvent cramer clairement brûlés
vifs où on parle pas de ça comme ça ne
rendront pas des brûlés vifs bien sûr
c'est pas juste une petite menace je
dirais presque une cartouche est
évidemment vous vous faites voilà vous
on le voit même votre attitude quoi vous
faites preuve de sérénité mais quand
même le bleu passe vaccinale il est
examinée en ce moment au sénat est ce qu
au moment de voter pardon de questions
presque intime n'y a pas un moment où
vous allez penser à cette à ce courrier
que vous allez reçoit vous avez reçus
dont nous deux comme dirait gérard
larcher ou dans la sérénité vieilles
troupes en a vu d'autres on en verra
d'autres et c'est d'ailleurs le sujet de
l'hémicycle c'est d'un sujet qui souvent
bien méconnu c'est pourquoi dans
l'hémicycle le public n'a pas accès
directement aux parlementaires pourquoi
tout est contrôlé à l'entrée c'est pour
pouvoir voter et délibérée dans la
plaine sérénité mais pour être dans la
plaine sérénité et aujourd'hui c'est les
mêmes sujets s'il faudrait pas qu'on
s'en prenne à votre domicile dans le
même temps voyez vous à votre famille ce
qui est étonnant c'est que les
cartouches dans le cas de l'oise ont été
envoyés au domicile de chacun d'entre
nous parlementaire forcé pas public
votre adresse or notre adresse n'est pas
publique et les gendarmes ont mis un peu
de temps à la trouver bon donc vous
voyez que c'était donc un acte délibéré
conscients qu'ils demandent à petit
travail donc j'espère que toute peine
mérite salaire mais en l'occurrence ce
que ce mal-être est une petite peine
ouais et et blanquette va avancer
bernardoni vous êtes maire depuis depuis
2000 20 depuis dernier scrutin un
soutien du président la république je le
disais vous étiez sur la liste et les
mots aux dernières élections régionales
en normandie je voudrais là aussi
entendre votre témoignage que vous est
il arrivé dans la nuit du 6 au 7
décembre dernier
oui bonsoir à tous effectivement à 2
heures du matin j'entends un gros bruit
à une explosion ben voilà cet été en fin
de compte le plus de la voiture qui ont
éclaté quand je me suis levé j'ai vu
qu'il y avait là incendie donc dans mon
garage c'est donc je me suis vite levé
je suis sorti et puis j'ai réveillé
d'abord mon épouse et puis voilà
effectivement
j'ai pu faire le constat que des deux
voitures étaient étaient en feu un
troisième véhicule que j'ai pu sortir et
c'est quand je suis revenu de déposer ma
voiture que mon épouse m'a dit regarde
sur le mur ce qu'était ce qui est écrit
et puis effectivement donc il y avait
des tags ont menacé de mort on demandait
à ce que zemmour devienne président
voilà avec une référence directe à la
candidature
d'eric zemmour un petit point
d'orthographe mais bref
c'est ici qu'est ce qu'il disait
précisément ces tags et et donc il y
avait un lien est ce qu'un lien direct
et effet dans votre esprit avec la crise
sanitaire puisqu'on va démarrer ce débat
vraiment sur 7 sur cette question là
puis après on élargira évidemment aux
différentes formes de violence entre les
juges
je ne peux pas vous dire s'il ya un lien
avec la crise sanitaire ce qui était
marqué c'est que je le maire soutient
macro nous avions une semaine avant créé
le comité de soutien pour la candidature
de manuel macron pour les
présidentielles donc est-ce que c'est
plutôt ça que pour la pour cette raison
qui a été visée quoi je pense que c'est
plutôt pour ça que pour la pour le que
pour le vaccin quoi il avait soumis et
comment vous vous analysez et là je suis
vraiment sur la question des antilles va
cependant quelle mouvance la violence
des antilles vax peut-elle se s'inscrire
d'après vous alors vous me posez une
petite colle pas si facile parce que on
en parlait tout à l'heure en coulisses
il n'y a pas encore de recherches et
d'études sociologiques sur les anti
vaccin est gentil passants qui sont deux
populations sensiblement différent
entend alors dans les antilles vague